bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de senna 360
voici les titres ap
la séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement c'est à suivre en direct et
en exclusivité sur notre antenne à
partir de 15 heures
parmi les thèmes à la réponse de
l'exécutif aux actes antisémites et aux
dégradations d'église sur fond de
mouvements le gilet jaune
le grand débat a séduit et s'installe le
chef de l'état et dans l'indre pour
promouvoir sa concertation dans les
zones rurales
quand les cinq gars en planche déjà sur
la phase 2 est la synthèse des
propositions le détail dans cette
édition la quiétude du sénat sur le
financement de la loi d'orientation sur
les mobilités pour les sénateurs le
compte n'y est pas il manquait cinq
cents millions d'euros à partir de 2020
ce qui fait craindre la création de
nouvelles taxes pour mettre en oeuvre ce
projet il promet d'ailleurs des
alternatives à la voiture le débat dans
un instant et je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez réagir sur twitter avec le
hashtag et senna 360 pour m'accompagner
cet après midi on retrouvera à tam tran
huy alexandre poussin en direct et du
sénat pour les réactions des sénateurs à
l'actualité aujourd'hui dans notre
métier plex à suivre
et on va d'ailleurs prendre tout de
suite la direction de l'hémicycle on
retrouve alexandre poussin bonjour
alexandre alors que l'ordre du jour de
cette séance de questions d'actualité
aujourd'hui
delphine les sénateurs vont poser de
nombreuses questions sur la violence
dans la société française et une
violence notamment antisémites avec un
chiffre alarmant la hausse de 74% des
actes antisémites en france en 2018 et
puis il sera aussi question de la
violence lors des manifestations des
gilet jaune pas plus tard que le
week-end dernier un véhicule militaire
de l'opération sentinelles a été
incendiée et le sénateur centriste
olivier cadic va demander au ministre de
l'intérieur
christophe castaner quand va-t-il
rétablir l'ordre républicain
d'autres sujets que la violence seront
abordés et notamment les fonctionnaires
puisque le gouvernement a dévoilé hier
sa réforme de l'aef de la fonction
publique avec un objectif la suppression
de 120 mille postes d'ici à 2022 et puis
les syndicats n'auront plus leur mot à
dire sur l'évolution de carrière des
fonctionnaires
voilà pour le programme de ces questions
d'actualité défini
merci beaucoup alexandre et on retrouve
à présent la salle des conférences du
sénat bonjour ça me quels seront vos
invités aujourd'hui
eh bien écoutez ça chez delphine
qu'aujourd'hui il sera notamment
question des adieux d'alain juppé à
bordeaux c'était l'un des temps forts
politique de cette journée un sans
contestation possible
j'en parlerai notamment avec franck
riester le ministre de la culture qui a
également co fondé le mouvement agir
auquel d'ailleurs et bien alain juppé
était venu rendre visite était venu
rendre visite au mois de septembre
dernier noter également un bien je
parlerai de ce même sujet avec gérard
longuet alors qu'alain juppé a également
motivé son départ et le fait qu'il aille
au conseil constitutionnel par la
violence du climat actuel et la
stigmatisation dont les élites font
aujourd'hui et les frais juge-t-il
on parlera bien sûr bien des nominations
conseil constitutionnel notamment avec
et bien jacques mézard il sera également
m'ont invité c'est le candidat du
président de la république à un ancien
ministre actuellement sénateur rdse du
cantal et je lui demanderais d'un quelle
voie il entend faire entendre parmi les
sages du conseil constitutionnel s'il
entend faire porter ce thème des
territoires
il sera enfin également question du
grand débat bien
ur de la taxe carbone avec les sénateurs
les républicains laurent du pont mais
aussi et bien de la loi sur les
mobilités dans un instant à mon micro
olivier jacquin sénateurs socialistes
merci beaucoup au tas mais on vous
retrouve dans un instant je les ai en
titre n'ont qu'à 500 millions d'euros
pour financer la loi mobilité
c'est le cri d'alarmé lancé par les
sénateurs les investissements prévus
dans les transports doivent pourtant
offrir des moyens de se déplacer sans
voiture individuelle cécile fiction
c'est un texte qui arrive
mi mars au sénat est pour le moment le
gouvernement ne sais pas comment il va
financer la loi mobilité
c'est en tout cas ce que dénonce hervé
mort et le président de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable au sénat après
l'abandon de la taxe poids lourds
décidée suite aux mouvements des gilet
jaune
il manquerait 500 millions d'euros par
an la ministre reconnaît elle même que
les 500 millions dont on a besoin chaque
année pour pour réaliser ce plan ils n'y
sont pas je trouve ça incroyable qu'on
arrive avec une réforme en reconnaissant
qu'elle n'est pas financé et qu'on verra
plus tard comment elle sera financée
hier élisabeth bornes la ministre des
transports auditionné au sénat a dit
vouloir attendre la fin du grand débat
nous ressortirons des mesures fiscales
le financement de la loi pourra alors
être intégrés plus tard au moment de la
discussion du budget je rappelle qu'il
s'agit d'une loi de programmation et
qu'aucune des lois de programmation par
exemple la loi de programmation
militaire n'est une loi de finances et
n'a donc vocation à intégrer des mesures
fiscales ou budgétaire mais selon hervé
maurey pour financer le projet le
gouvernement aurait un autre plan
utiliser les recettes des radars et des
pv le sénateur a pu consulter un
document de bercy qui prévoit
d'augmenter les recettes de ces amendes
de 300 millions à 650 millions d'euros
d'ici 2022 radars n'ont pas été créées
pour générer des recettes pour l'état
mais à la fin de satisfaire les
objectifs de sécurité routière
si bercy près en août toutes les
fiscalités qui ont un objectif d'intérêt
général pour remplir les caisses de
l'état
c'est évidemment un problème en matière
de sécurité routière en matière
d'écologie
pour hervé mort et les fronts ci seront
heureux d'apprendre que le gouvernement
envisage de doubler les
monde pour excès de vitesse sachant que
l'une des cibles principales des gilet
jaune sont les radars automatiques
dégradé à 60% depuis le début du mou et
avant d'en débattre avec mes invités on
retourne salle des conférences pour
nouvelles réactions et vous autres
années avec le sénateur socialiste
olivier jacquin c'est tabou oui olivier
jacquin d'avoir ce que vous êtes inquiet
face au manque de financement de la loi
mobilité c'était au coeur hier de
l'audition de la ministre elisabeth
bornes
bien sûr on est inquiet on s'attendait à
une loi extrêmement au champ très vaste
avec des perspectives intéressantes de
financement des infrastructures
après tout les travaux qui avaient été
faits puis là on se trouve avec une
boîte à outils qui propose quelques
outils mais on n'a pas les moyens de les
utiliser
demain puisqu'il n'ya pas les
financements qui vont avec et c'est
quand même inquiétant oui la ministre
donc il ya ne vous a pas convaincu
on a entendu la passe d'armes notamment
qu'il ya vu avec le sénateur centriste
président de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire hervé maurey
qui juge que le gouvernement vous même
financé la loi grâce aux recettes des
radars et grâce au doublement de ses
recettes
alors là je partage tout à fait on a eu
l'audition de monsieur béchu président
de laffitte qui est l agence qui finance
les infrastructures de transports
terrestres et ferroviaires mais quand
vous l'entendez qu'il dit qu'il ne sait
pas comment il bouclera le budget 2010 9
etc en quelque sorte ça dépendra la date
à laquelle seront réparés les radars
c'est plus qu'inquiétant c'est plus
qu'inquiétant il s'agit de financer des
infrastructures et donc du très long
terme
et là on fait de la cavalerie avec des
amendes de police c'est une catastrophe
c'est pathétique mais alors attendez
voir absolument
mais attendez moi je suis étonné de voir
certains collègues parlementaires qu'ils
sur un texte de loi disent ils est pas
suffisamment financé puis au moment du
vote du budget 10 ya trop de dépenses
publiques et il faut baisser la dépense
publique à la dépense publique et les
taxes majorité sénatoriale par exemple
et sur cette question de financement
je trouve le système suédois plutôt
intéressant du point de vue de la
fiscalité verte parce que je suis pour
la fiscalité verte à terme une fiscalité
juste il n'est pas question que l'avion
ne soit pas taxé alors que une aide à
domicile qui va travailler péniblement
au service de ses concitoyens avec un
vieux diesels soient taxés et soit en
soit considéré comme travailleur pauvre
d'accord donc là il y a de la justice à
remettre dans la fiscalité verte je
pense qu'on a de quoi financer et je
vous pose cette question de la cohérence
à la fois on baisse certains types de
fiscalité sur certains publics et après
on vient pleurer qu'il n'y a pas assez
de financements pour financer le long
terme
votre commentaire sur le fait que le
ministère est sous-traité la préparation
de la loire un cabinet d'avocats privé
tout d'abord c'est une initiative très
inhabituelles notamment pour un exposé
des motifs alors que c'est un acte très
politique normalement effectivement moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est la maîtrise
publique
est ce qu'il y ait ou non maîtrise
publique après comment elle est opérée
ça peut être une question secondaire
alors sur l'exposé des motifs d'une loi
c'est absolument
ça peut paraître choquant qu'on sous
traite mais ça les fait que ça jugé très
satisfaisant par le conseil d'état
l'ensemble lui oui oui mais la question
c'est si on trouve ou non de la
compétence alors là effectivement
conseil d'état nous dit en plus ça a été
sous traitée puis c'est pas top
donc là il ya une vraie question une
question sur l'effectif des ministères
par exemple on a dit que sncf n'était
plus un monopole d'état c'est une
entreprise où l expertise b chez ssl
j'avais questionné la ministre à dire
n'y aurait-il pas à la dgitm à recréer
des postes pour effectuer vos missions
d'évaluation de stratège et de contrôle
et on a des vraies questions qui se
posent maintenant vous savez le recours
à l'expertisé extérieure peut être un
aussi un motif d' enrichissement pas des
finances publiques mais du texte et des
contenus et bien merci beaucoup olivier
jacquin d'avoir répondu à m
merci avons tablé on va poursuivre ce
débat en plateau avec mes invités j'ai
le plaisir d'accueillir camille laus
bonjour bien
vous êtes journée spécialiste des
questions de transport chez que mon
texte sage accueille également sur ce
plateau michel dagbert bonjour vous êtes
un sénateur socialiste du pas-de-calais
bienvenue à vous jean françois longeot
et également avec nous bonjour vous êtes
assez l'inter centre et ceux du doubs et
puis michel vaspart on jouera sénateurs
l ère des côtes d'armor
première question pour vous camille
seule hausse puisqu'on voit la
commission du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire du sénat
ici keith alerte qui s'inquiètent du non
financement de cette loi d'orientation
sur les mobilités c'était prévisible
selon vous oui c'était assez prévisible
parce que depuis le début en fait le
ministère est resté assez flou renvoyant
à plus tard un certain nombre de
questions que ce soit sur le financement
des infrastructures dont la ministre a
toujours dit que pour 2019
il n'y avait pas de problème de toute
façon même en 2019 il va finalement il y
en avoir un puisque ça s'appuyer
notamment sur des recettes de radars qui
finalement sont pas celles qu'on
attendait et elle avait dit il faut une
nouvelle ressource à partir de 2020 il
faut 500 millions d'euros quand même
c'est quand même une somme qui n'est pas
négligeable
les débats et sont en cours et ça fait
quand même un an et demi maintenant
qu'on en parle
il est question de s'appuyer notre
enfant notamment sur une vignette poids
lourd au moment de la réforme de la sncf
quand on avait les cheminots dans la rue
n'était pas question d'ajouter les
routiers à l'automne il était un moment
non plus donc le dossier toujours en
discussions mais ils n'aboutissent pas
pour l'instant
michel vaspart le compte n'y est pas je
lisais comment on va financer cette aile
loi mobilité
écoutez pour le moment de rien c'est si
c'est ça qui est tout à fait étonnant
c'est qu'on attendait on attendait
beaucoup je crois que ce soit les élus
locaux les élus en général ou nos
concitoyens à tâter attendait beaucoup
de cette loi mobilité hors ya un certain
nombre de dispositifs mais ya pas de
financement et il n'y a pas non plus la
totalité des inscriptions en matière
d'investissements qu'on pouvait être en
droit d'attendre peut-être qu'on en
reparlera j'ai eu l'occasion hier
d'interpeller la mini
notamment sur les risques que on faire
encourir si on ne fait pas certaines
infrastructures ou si on les inscrit pas
l'avenir du port de marseille fos par
exemple jean françois ozon votre regard
sur ces incertitudes qui pèsent sur le
financement de cette loi mobilité
oui si vous voulez cette loi et elle est
très attendue sur nos territoires
quand on en parle effectivement nos
concitoyens les élus attendent cette loi
est aujourd'hui bon s'aperçoit que le
financement est malheureusement absent
alors bien sûr il ya un certain nombre
de phénomènes qui font que l'on
l'écotaxe été supprimé et a pour des
raisons qui ont été peut-être un petit
peu rapide parce que je pense que
c'était quotaxe qui quand même peser
taxer les véhicules qui est des
véhicules étrangers
notre territoire je pense que c'était
quand même important parce que
aujourd'hui
ben les routiers étrangers non seulement
il s'alimente pas en carburant sur notre
territoire mais ils prennent nos routes
nationales nos routes départementales
et puis derrière et ben on n'a aucun
financement qui ont qui est entré et moi
je suis très inquiète parce que les
infrastructures dont a besoin le monde
rural a et notamment un certain nombre
d'entreprises pour que les personnels
puissent venir travailler
je ne sais pas comment on va réussir à
mettre en place ces ses déplacements moi
j'ai une idée et c'est effectivement
reprendre le système d des transports
scolaires mais qui financera la région
le département les communautés de
communes et avec quels moyens
c'est là où effectivement le bât blesse
c'est créer
recettes supplémentaires une ressource
nouvelle on disait dans le contexte pas
facile d'aider les gens oui tout à fait
mais je pense alors les experts n'ont
pas bonne presse par les temps qui
courent auprès de nos concitoyens mais à
un moment donné il faut bien poser une
expertise sur des sujets d'une ampleur
aussi aussi grande et sur les modes
puisque vous l'avez vu cette l'homme on
reprend les principaux modes de
déplacement que sont la route le faire
et la voie d'eau aujourd'hui
manifestement le compte n'y est pas même
si les travaux du conseil d'orientation
des infrastructures sur lequel s'appuie
la ministre pour amener la loi devant le
parlement avait proposé trois scénarii
et c'est le scénario 2 qui semble-t-il
avait était retenu aujourd'hui dans la
loi on s'aperçoit qu'on est en deçà de
ce que nous prévoyons au niveau du coi
est manifestement dès 2019 il ya le
problème de financement de la fit avec
cette baisse des recettes de radars mais
pour autant je pense que le débat ne
doit nous permettre d'améliorer le texte
nous aurons en commission probablement
mais à plus forte raison durant le débat
un certain nombre de propositions et je
pense aussi qu'il faut entendre nos
concitoyens il ya un certain nombre
d'ouvertures qu'ils sont majeurs pour
moi dans ce texte le fait de dire que
l'ensemble du territoire national doit
être couvert par une autorité
organisatrice des mobilités ça me semble
aller dans le bon sens ensuite la
manière dont on va le mettre en oeuvre
est-ce que ça doit être descendant ou
est-ce qu'il faut laisser un espace pour
la concertation notamment à l'échelle
régionale puisque les régions seront
chef de file à 2
ces autorités de la mobilité
organisatrice de la mobilité sur les
territoires et je pense que là il ya
cette souplesse qui doit nous permettre
territoire par territoire d'améliorer
rapidement et sensiblement la mobilité
de nos concitoyens localement on la joue
et camille solo c'est là aussi il ya des
incertitudes des raisons peur d'un
passionnant avoir lé moyen est bien de
proposer des alternatives au tout
voiture
oui parce que en pour l'instant en fait
il n'y a qu' il ya 80% du territoire la
ministre a l'habitude de le rappeler qui
est pas couverts par ce que vous disiez
une autorité organisatrice donc une
collectivité qui prend en charge les la
question de la mobilité c'est 80% du
territoire c'est quand même 30 % de la
population
en plus c'est probablement là que se
situent les foyers des gilet jaune
donc tu vois c'est mais dans tous ces
territoires là qui vont être couverts
pour l'instant on n'a pas encore décidé
non plus de qu'elle voulait être la
ressource là où actuellement il ya une
autorité organisatrice est ce qu'on
appelle le versement transport qui est
une taxe dont s'acquittent les
entreprises d'au moins 20 salariés pour
financer les transports collectifs
il a été question un moment de l'étendre
à tout le territoire mais le débat un
peu c'est un peu enlisée donc on est
toujours là encore dans la réflexion
donc ça fait quand même deux deux
aspects où on est toujours en réflexion
le ministère dit qu' il y aura une
ressource ça a été acté même par le
gouvernement mais on sait pas quelle
forme elle va prendre
ils se disent assez agnostique sur la
forme qu'elle doit prendre mais alors ça
m'a plu michel massart ça pourrait être
cette vignette poids lourds on en parle
et elle pourrait ressurgir selon vous
dans le débat pour financer le coûteux
je crois que les c'est totalement ouvert
puisque la ministre nous l'a dit moi ce
que je crois vraiment c'est qu'on est
dans un contexte excessivement compliqué
difficile qu'ils n'étaient que ce
n'était pas le cas il ya deux ans ou
trois ans mais aujourd'hui c'est
particulièrement compliqué et il va être
effectivement très compliqué de mettre
en place toutes formes de taxes ou
toutes sortes de taxes que ce soit au
niveau des entreprises où que ce soit au
niveau des particuliers donc pour
résoudre la quadrature du sial du cercle
ça va pas être si simple que cela
moi je crois en tout cas que il va
falloir aussi que nos concitoyens
si on veut un développement économique
si on veut réduire le chômage
si on veut lutter véritablement contre
ce fléau qu'est le chômage et faire en
sorte qu'on retrouve de l'emploi dans
nos territoires
il va aussi falloir qu'on est une
acceptabilité peut-être d'un financement
et les infrastructures car à chaque fois
que nous décidons d'une infrastructure
il y à de telle levée de boucliers qu'il
nous faut quand on y arrive
10 ans 15 ans 20 ans et l'a
véritablement il ya il va y avoir il va
falloir à mon avis que les élus qu'ils
soient nationaux que ce soit les
ministres que ce soit les élus locaux on
puisse aussi dire à nos concitoyens
qu'on ne pourra pas faire les choses si
on n'a pas de ressources car il était
anciennement dans les territoires cette
question de la mobilité jean françois
longeot on voit notamment à travers le
grand débat à travers les consultations
qui sont organisées ce thème les
déplacements on revient souvent au coeur
des discussions
il revient au coeur des discussions et
quand on parle par exemple à la taxe
transport ni mais la taxe transport dans
les territoires ruraux
vous avez des petites entreprises
comment comment vont tes le faire c'est
impossible et on a besoin si on veut
garder notre tissu économique dans ces
territoires
on a effectivement besoin à un moment
donné de mettre en place un certain
nombre de mobilité alors que ce soit par
le biais de deux bus que ce soit par le
biais de covoiturage que ce soit par ce
biais là mais derrière il faudra quand
même bien qu'on puisse trouver un
certain nombre de moyens il y avait il y
avait il y avait là la taxe urbaine qui
avait été envisagé et qui a été
abandonné parce que je pense qu'il ya eu
aussi je veux dire un manque de
pédagogie un manque de de travail sur ce
sur ce dossier qui était d'ailleurs qui
date est 2010un faut le rappeler quand
même et sur lequel on aurait pu avoir un
certain nombre de rentrées d'argent mais
il fallait derrière et bien qu'il y ait
des compensations parce qu'on
socialement on peut pas et on peut pas
continuer parents prenez la la
ville de paris comment vous expliquer
qu'une semaine vous roulerez pas avec un
véhicule qui a la plus de dix ans ce
conte un véhicule qui a plus de dix ans
ce sont en général les gens qui sont
dans les situations les plus démunis
donc il faudra bien et si une solution
il ya une vraie contradiction dans tout
ça parce que ce mouvement il est parti
d'un refus d'une hausse des taxes sur
les prix de l'essence et avec des
revendications derrière de deux
fractures territoriales vous le disiez
de un besoin de répondre à des questions
de désenclavement horse cette taxe sur
les carburants devaient servir à
financer sa donc les citoyens s'y sont
opposés parce qu'ils avaient la
sensation que cet argent était juste là
pour les taxes et est allé à rentrer
dans les caisses de l'état on savait pas
trop à quoi ça allait servir il je pense
qu'il y avait effectivement une question
de pédagogie et de lisibilité et
probablement que si on leur avait
expliqué alors il y avait aussi la
question c'était pour faire évoluer les
comportements
mais ce qu'ils réclament aujourd'hui est
justement mis en suspens par le début du
mouvement
donc c'est un peu le serpent qui se mord
la queue oui moi je rejoins le collègue
sur ce cette obligation de vérité des
coûts et des coûts des infrastructures
notamment et nous en sommes comptables
les uns et les autres notamment
s'agissant du ferroviaire
un parti pris a été celui de nos
gouvernements successifs sur les lignes
à grande vitesse
il n'y a pas un élu d'une grande
métropole qui ne pouvait concevoir de
voir sa métropole desservi par la grande
vitesse
mais pendant le temps où on a fait la
grande vitesse le réseau a vieilli il
s'est fortement dégradé et aujourd'hui
ce sont les trajets du quotidien 'the à
dire toutes ces personnes qui se rendent
sur les métropoles pour y travailler qui
en payent le prix d'une certaine manière
donc c'est à cela que la loi doit aussi
contribuer c'est à dire à réorienter ça
veut pas dire qu'on ne va plus faire de
grande vitesse puisqu'il ya des lignes
qui sont concernés j'ai une collègue qui
est intervenu hier sur
le paris orléans limoges toulouse ça va
se faire mais en même temps il faut
avoir à l'esprit que l'investissement
sur le routier par exemple s'est
fortement diminué ces dernières années
les collectivités en charge des voiries
que ce soit au niveau communal ou
département a plongé ces dernières
partout où il ya des départements qui
ont réussi à maintenir un niveau
d'investissement il y en a d'autres qui
sont à la peine et donc il ya cette
question nous avons les uns et les
autres conduit beaucoup d'auditions et
lorsque nous entendons un certain nombre
de ceux qui sont venus à notre rencontre
il nous alerte sur le fait notamment
dans l'organisation la gouvernance des
mobilités sur les territoires sur le
fait de ne pas rajouter des intervenants
c'est notamment le discours des
présidents de région qui nous disent oui
mais ne remet tait pas les communautés
de communes autour de la table parce
qu'on a déjà discuté avec simplifier les
choses aient besoin de simplification
mais si besoin d'explications absolument
vous savez quand je repense que disait
autres collègues journalistes tout à
l'heure quand cette taxe a été envisagée
à nos concitoyens avait vraiment
l'impression que c'était une taxe que
l'on mettait pour venir combler les
déficits budgétaires et je me rappelle
avant qu'elle soit abandonnée avoir fait
un certain nombre de propositions et
d'amendements pour dire mais attendez il
faudrait reverser 10 euros j'avais
proposé pour les régions pour qu'ils
puissent comme il ya le dire le collègue
entretenir les voies ferrées il fallait
leur verser un certain nombre de
collectivités les départements qui
effectivement on des kilomètres de
routes rares à entretenir et si on avait
bien voulu regarder le produit est que
ce produit soit affectée aux routiers au
ferroviaire
en un mot au transport fluvial au
fluvial et je pense qu'effectivement ça
aurait été mieux perçu 1 parce que là on
a l'impression qu'on prenait 15
milliards on le met dedans
un tonneau percé la contradiction à la
fois ce besoin de mobilité grandissant
chez les français mais les difficultés à
accepter de nouvelles taxes ou how a
payé plus cher l'essence par exemple
oui c'est exactement ce que je vous
disais tout de suite moi je vais je
pense qu'un problème d'accès
d'acceptabilité 1
aujourd'hui encore plus qu'hier et c'est
effectivement complexe aujourd'hui à
résoudre alors le grand débat je ne sais
pas si on va en sortir quelque chose je
ne suis pas très optimiste
il était d'ailleurs décalé la prison
compte c'est ce que vont faire nos
consultants il souhaitait que le dés le
grand débat fini sa vendeuse avant de
nous parler effectivement des
financements et de trouver des
financements notamment pour la fidh ça a
été dit tout à l'heure
mais aujourd'hui la fit est exemple ne
peut même pas bouclé son budget donc sur
2019 on sait très bien qu'on n'aura même
pas on ne frappe
on ne mettra pas en oeuvre les dépenses
qui était prévu fâché je pense que vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure et c'est une
réalité
donc on est dans un contexte
particulièrement compliqué il va quand
même falloir qu'on en sorte
un car on ne peut pas penser qu'il ne
faut plus d'infrastructures on ne va pas
avoir simplement que le numérique le
numérique est un atout considérable
c'est un apport également pour
l'industrie traditionnelle mais nous
avons besoin d'industries
traditionnelles d'activités économiques
traditionnels et la france ne peut pas
uniquement reposer son activité
économique sur le tourisme
oui non c'est pas un point de désaccord
on aura l'occasion de débattre dans
quelques
jours quelques semaines mais ce que je
regrette par exemple c'est que depuis
que nous discutons hormis par votre
intervention tout à l'heure sur la
pollution à paris nous ne prenons pas
assez en compte me semble-t-il la
mutation qui doit s'opérer et cette
mutation au profit des générations par
rapport à l'environnement par rapport
aux problématiques de pollution par
rapport aux problématiques de santé
je pense que ça doit être aussi au coeur
de notre réflexion nous avons aussi à
soutenir notre industrie notamment sur
ce nouveau modèle est regardé les
expérimentations qui se fond j'étais la
semaine dernière avec le président mort
et à rouen sur le véhicule autonome et
tous ces jeunes ingénieurs dont j'ai
compris que en fait ils ne travaillent
pas ils s'amusent ils s'amusent comme
des petits fous
non non c'est blague à part un c'est
c'est un vrai boulot mais ça augure de
très bonnes choses pour l'avenir
est ce qu'on sera à ce rendez vous là
est ce qu'on sera capable d'assumer cela
est d'accompagner nos concitoyens vers
ce changement de mode sur arrêtez
l'autosolisme par exemple le département
que j'ai eu l'honneur de présider à
déployer des aires de covoiturage il ya
de l'autopartage il ya des plateformes
qui se met en place et donc sévère tout
cela qu'on doit aller sans pour autant
négliger les modes traditionnels
oui nous avons un réseau routier qui est
formidable en france et il faut
l'entretenir et le régénérer nous avons
un réseau ferré à régénérer mais nous
avons aussi la chance d'avoir une voie
d'eau on ne parle pas assez de voies
navigables de france et des moyens dont
ils ont besoin
lécluse par exemple de méricourt qui
méritent grandement d'être remise à
niveau et tout ce que cela peut avoir
sur le fret sur les voyages
d'orientation des mobilités mais elle
prend suffisamment en compte justement
la mobilité du futur à quoi
ressemblera-t-elle cette mobilité de
demain
oui en fait on se focalise sur l'aller
les infrastructures et le financement
mais dans cette loi il ya quand même
énormément de choses qui sont peut-être
moins grand
blick aussi dont on parlement on a un
moment on s'est concentré sur les péages
urbains qui finalement n'y figure plus
mais il ya des dizaines de mesures en
réalité on pourrait en parler des heures
il ya ce volet programmation des
infrastructures mais il ya dedans aussi
des choses pour soutenir le
développement du vélo pour le
covoiturage pour l'ouverture des données
transport pour qu'on puisse avoir des
applications qui centralise tout cas il
ya énormément de choses et la question
est enfin là je crois que c'était dit
dans un de vos reportages tout à l'heure
c'est une boîte à outils encore faut-il
que les gens à s'en saisissent que les
collectivités s'en saisissent et surtout
qu'elles aient les moyens de le faire
après bien merci à vous à camille solo
sera l'occasion d'en reparler jean
françois longeot de cette loi mobilité
dont l'examen débute au sénat le 19 mars
merci à vous michel vaspart merci à
michel à dagbert vous savez le chef de
l'état et d'en rejoindre aujourd'hui
pour promouvoir sa concertation dans les
zones rurales
hé les gars ont quant à eux bien prépare
déjà à la suite de ce grand débat on
voit emmanuel macron sur ces images aux
côtés de jacqueline gourault il était
invité par vanik berberian assez le
président de l'association des maires
ruraux pour que ce grand débat
s'installe un peu partout en france et
je le disais les gars on prépare
également la suite ils réfléchissent à
la manière de synthétiser toutes les
contributions envoyées les explications
de sa liens de chiens plus de 3000
réunions ont déjà été organisées dans le
cadre du grand débat national
mais seuls six ans ont fait l'objet d'un
compte rendu
la faute pour les cinq garant du
processus à une forme de restitution
trop encadré sans doute là modalités de
restitution n'est pas la plus fluide la
plus simple et c'est pourquoi nous
engageons le gouvernement a facilité
la restitution libre de des réunions
d'initiatives locales plutôt que de
passer par les questionnaires en ligne
dans un mois la phase des réunions
locales s'achèvera pour laisser place à
celle des conférences citoyennes 18
seront organisées sur tout le territoire
les 15 16 22 et 23 mars
elles rassembleront chacune 100 citoyens
les garants recommande de les tirer au
sort par génération aléatoire de numéros
de téléphone et surtout qu'ils puissent
avoir une vue d'ensemble des
contributions pour faire émerger des
propositions il nous paraît important
que une sorte de pré synthèse soit
réalisée début mars à partir des
contributions en ligne à partir des
comptes rendus des réunions locales et
que cette première pré synthèse alimente
les conférences régionales citoyenne
pourquoi est-ce que nous avons ça en
tête parce que nous pensons que il est
important que le départ progresse
évoluent les cinq gars en promettent
d'être vigilants sur les méthodes des
prestataires qui réaliseront la synthèse
des contributions
on en compte déjà neuf cent mille sur le
site internet du grand débat national et
on retourne la salle des conférences
pour une nouvelle réaction avec vous
êtes en train de nuit avec le sénateur l
ère de la haute-loire laurent duplomb
oui laurent duplomb on l'a entendu à
l'instant le travail de synthèse sur le
grand débat est en cours comment
voyez-vous et bien l'irruption dans ce
grand débat d'un du débat sur la taxe
carbone qui a fait son retour hier matin
et la porte a été très vite refermée par
le premier ministre mais aussi par le
président la république
je pense que le fait que la porte soit
refermée et plutôt quelque chose qui va
dans le bon sens il ne faut pas oublier
que le 17 novembre si beaucoup de
français sont descendus dans la rue
c'est parce qu'ils estimaient que sur la
transition écologique d'abord on leur
mentait puisqu'une partie très grosse
partie de la taxe qui était prévu ne
servait pas à la transition écologique
et puis deuxièmement je pense que c'est
aussi la possibilité de redéfinir
qu'elle pourrait être notre politique
entame de transition écologique et qu'on
sorte de cette écologie punitive qui
consiste à mettre que des taxes et à ne
pas regarder déjà dans un premier temps
quels sont les efforts que nous pouvons
avoir fait dans notre pays
comment nous pouvons ainsi thé
positivement ces efforts je pense qu'il
faut passer d'une écologie punitive à
une écologie incitative
ce débat sur la taxe carbone est ce que
ça montre qu'il est un vrai débat dans
la majorité sur ce point là où on disait
que bien certaines choses étaient dictés
d'avant-centre cas certains hommes
politiques je pense que la problématique
de la transition écologique c'est que
elle répond à une forme de dogmatisme
écologique et que quand on regarde
certaines règles je pense qu'on a
beaucoup de choses à réfléchir avant de
vouloir obligatoirement sur taxer taxer
et matraquer fiscalement la
problématique du gasoil ou de l'essence
je vous donnerai un exemplaire en france
les caisses sont vides actuellement donc
on comprend bien pourquoi elle le débat
repart sur la table sur la taxe carbone
mais parce qu'on veut pas on veut pas
ouvrir le débat dans un plus larges
horizons
si on veut véritablement regarder la
totalité des choses il faut qu'on puisse
remettre sur la table la problématique
du nucléaire est ce que continue ou
est-ce qu'on arrête ça c'est quelque
chose qui n'a pas été tranchée chaque
gouvernement dit un peu la sienne ont
fait en pesos naïm on ne ferme pas on le
ferme on ne ferme pas on veut fermer un
réacteur sur deux mais on sait même pas
comment on veut le faire en tous les cas
ce qu'est ce que conduite derrière c'est
que le français estime que
l'augmentation du prix de l'électricité
alors qu'on lui prône que l'électricité
va être obligatoirement impacté puisque
si on ferme des réacteurs ça veut dire
que les charges fixes de ses recteurs là
se reportent sur les autres je pense
qu'il faut qu'on ouvre le débat sur de
nouveaux horizons
les nouveaux horizons il y en a plein la
méthanisation le photovoltaïque peuvent
en être des solutions
je vous rappelle qu'en france il y à
40000 seuil sur nos rivières qui ne sont
pas utilisés pour faire
l'hydroélectricité tout simplement parce
que l'argent ce française de la
biodiversité règle avec un dogme
particulier les règles administratives
pour interdire l'ouverture de ces seuils
c'est soit y existait et fonctionner il
ya deux cents ans pourquoi il ne
fonctionne pas aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup laurent duplomb d'avoir
répondu à mes questions merci beaucoup
tu avais on va voir à présent comment se
passent vos grands débats sur le terrain
nous sommes allés à floirac conduiront
dans à quelques kilomètres de bordeaux
est la ville compte dix sept mille
habitants et vous allez voir un parti
possible au grand débat national pour
l'équipe municipale qui était déjà très
engagé dans la démocratie participative
c'était d'ailleurs une évidence et un
reportage de béatrice faisant florac en
gironde à quelques kilomètres de
bordeaux
la ville d'environ dix sept mille
habitants participent aussi au grand
débat national pour l'équipe municipale
déjà très engagé dans la démocratie
participative
c'était une évidence en tout cas moi je
vous invite à débattre c'est toujours
intéressant
on a souhaité mettre à disposition les
moyens nécessaires pour que les citoyens
s'expriment
nous avons mis donc une salle du
personnel municipal sur chaque atelier
qui prend le récolement de la parole des
citoyens puisque nous ferons une
restitution en fin de journée transition
écologique démocratie et citoyenneté
fiscalité ou encore organisation de
l'état et des services publics
difficile de savoir à l'avancé si les
quatre grands thèmes retenus par le
gouvernement vont attirer les habitants
mais l'opération semble réussi on avait
un veau l'incertitude puisqu'on savait
pas en organise sur une journée on ne
savait pas si les citoyens allaient s'en
saisir si comment ils allaient venir
dans quelles dispositions moi je suis
très satisfaite que le citoyen vienne
s'intéresse débattent échanges propose
fasse un diagnostic aussi on a besoin
d'heures de diagnostiquer et à chaque
table les débats sont animés puis
entendu personne dire qu'on va baisser d
opulence et c'est très intéressant ça
nous a remonté parce que ça c'est une
indication pour le président je voulais
participer à ce grand débat parce que
c'est important qu'on puisse se donner
notre la trabi on fait quoi bien ça ce
qu'il ya en ressorte quelque chose
d'important pour notre eau notre pays la
restitution
l'autre grande inconnue de ce grand
débat pour henry il faudra rester
attentif à ce que le gouvernement fera
de tout cela si le postulat de départ
c'est de dire on va continuer des
réformes ultralibérales comme c'est
actuellement le cas
on va vous laisser débattre
et dans quelques mois on remettra sur le
sur la table de travail les réformes
ultralibérales
le débat aura servi à rien même si c'est
un grand brouhaha aujourd'hui que chacun
s'exprime parfois autour d'une même
table on donne des idées contradictoires
il n'empêche qu'on a la parole et qu'il
faut nous écouter et les élus locaux
on devrait dans ce sens toute la journée
lister les idées à répéter pour être sûr
de rendre compte au plus près jusqu'à la
restitution finale en fin de journée
donc encore un grand merci pour votre
participation prochaine étape le 15 mars
date de clôture du grand débat les élus
devront remettre l'ensemble de ses
propositions au préfet qui est chargé
ensuite de les transmettre au
gouvernement dont les conclusions seront
scrutés à la loupe par l'ensemble des
français
mais on continue le débat en plateau
avec mes invités je désire daguerre
françoise cartron bonjour c'est la crise
c'est la république en marche de la
gironde également avec nous y sommes et
chevalier bonjour vous êtes sénateur et
l'air de la mayenne et puis jean durand
également sénateur socialiste de la
saône et loire
on voit un ce grand débat sur le terrain
avec cette illustration dans votre
département françoise cartron comment
faire maintenant pour que cet exercice
inédit ne soit pas vain est-ce que le
gouvernement va pouvoir prendre en
compte l'intégralité des contributions
au bal intégralité non parce qu'on le
sait dans les contributions yahia il ya
des propos contradictoires mais tout le
travail c'est d'abord compilé tout ce
qui a été dit que les citoyens n'ai pas
le sentiment que leur parole n'a été
écartée et puis après ben c'est comme
tout débat toute rencontre tout dialogue
qui est instaurée il faut il ya une
espèce de négociation et il y aura des
axes forts c'est-à-dire les reprend les
revendications qu'ils reviendront le
plus souvent les choses qui sont
affirmés de manière la plus forte iq et
dont on ressent quelque chose de très
profond dans la population
je crois que ça c'est une exigence pour
le gouvernement de répondre à cette
attente parce que ce grand débat crée
une attente chez nos concitoyens et donc
il faut surtout pas décevoir
ça c'est le risque à jérôme durain est
ce qu elles sont
d'ores et déjà biaisé synthèse ces
contributions selon vous non je veux pas
aller dans le procès d'intention jusque
là mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un risque et
il faut pas être dupe
c'est un grand débat il ya de grands
enjeux de grandes attentes comme
françoise cartron et il faut faire
attention il faudrait pas que ce soit
une opération de cavalerie dire qu'on ne
répond pas aux questions qui sont posées
on en pose dans de nouvelles et puis
finalement on essaye de gagner un peu de
temps la situation sociale est quand
même tendu le soutien aux mouvements des
gilets jaunes restent élevés
beaucoup sont c'est ça commence à se
tasser commencent à fléchir des gens
quand même ça demeure cette affaire-là
n'est pas derrière nous donc il ya
quelque chose qui s'est levé il faut y
répondre effectivement la question
désormais du traitement du débouché est
essentielle quel traitement à la guerre
michel rollier salon vaut pour
l'exécutif pour justement ne pas
décevoir les attentes qui sont suscitées
par cette grande concertation des
réponses concrètes aux attentes des
français sur le point du pouvoir d'achat
qui revient énormément sur les questions
de sécurité d'une façon générale je
crois que ce grand débat et il vit dans
les territoires déjà parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'élus locaux qui se sont
mobilisés pour l'organiser donc moi je
salue cet engagement moi je pense que le
l'exécutif a sa part de responsabilité
dans la situation sociale et la tension
dans le pays donc il fallait trouver un
moyen d'apaisement un moyen de retrouver
pas céder des ronds points aux tables
rondes selon la formule du président
larcher donc on est dans cette séquence
là je note que dans les nombreux débats
il ya comme ça a été dit il ya beaucoup
d'expressions diverses et parfois très
contradictoires ça donne l'occasion
parfois d'ailleurs aux élus et à nous
mêmes en tant que parlementaire de de
rétablir certaines vérités
parce qu'il ya aussi beaucoup de
contre-vérités qui circulent donc voila
ce débat ce temps l'année n'est pas
inutile dans la démocratie même si dans
notre pays alors qu'elles ont des basses
oeuvres liées à ce que les
parlementaires sont parfois nous en
cause parce qu'il a beaucoup de choses
avec parfois de l'agressivité aussi dans
ces réunions
cette fois oui 2
de la tension mais justement il faut
pouvoir corriger en disant voilà ce que
l'on fait on dit évidemment le sénat est
moins connue par les citoyens que
l'assemblée nationale ce qui est logique
puisque le sénat le collège électoral
pour il a les sénateurs et plus limitée
donc après il faut faire la pédagogie
sur ce que fait le sénat à quoi elle est
là l'intérêt du bicamérisme dans notre
système politique
ce grand débat peut permettre de faire
la pédagogie sosa en saas et c'est utile
après il faut se méfier effectivement
qu'à l'arrivée si il ya une consultation
référendaire ou autre qui est pas des
questions qu'ils soient biaisés
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens et que
voilà où on attend vraiment aujourd'hui
du concret et que ce grand débat ce ne
se limite pas une vaste opération de
communication autres pays parce que vous
parlez de tension ce matin marlène
schiappa était l'invité d'un trop
matinal territoire l'info elle elle
parle justement d'une certaine
agressivité parfois je vous propose de
l'écouter geoffrey réagir après
françoise cartron je crois que le
respect se perd en fait ils envoient
avec les réseaux sociaux et la façon
dont les politiques ou entre les
français le respect entre tous non de
façon générale il ya une augmentation
des violences gratuites et des actes de
haine de l'autre extrêmement
préoccupante +74 % des actes antisémites
it + 60 des acomptes six mille pardons +
60 % des actes homophobes d'une part et
d'autre part effectivement un clivage
entre les élus et les citoyens de plus
en plus fort moi je dirais qu'il ya des
tentatives d'agressivité mais lorsque je
prends toutes les questions lorsqu'elles
sont posés avec respect mais dès lors
que je vois qu'on manque de respect
surtout aux autres participants je vous
renvoie les gens dans les cordes hier
avant-hier j'étais en lot et j'étais en
dordogne pardon et il ya trois femmes
qui témoignaient de leur situation de
mère isolée et un monsieur s'en est pris
à elle et les invectives et en étant
très méprisant plixi voulu s'en prendre
à quelqu'un il s'en prenait à moi mais
pas à ces femmes qui étaient venus
témoigner
il ya aussi de l'agressivité de la
violence finalement qui s'exprime à la
fois marlène schiappa le rappeler un
clivage entre les citoyens et les élus
qui est peut-être mise à jour aussi à
travers cette crise ce mouvement d'un
gilet jaune et qui ressort ressurgit
aussi sur les femmes hommes et de toutes
manières depuis moi je note depuis
quelques années il ya une violence qui
était en train de
instituée dans notre société une
violence des rapports entre les
différentes catégories de citoyens et on
le voit bien il n'ya même pas qu'une
violence entre les vents vers les élus
qui sont la cible parfois de de tous les
ressentiments mais il y avait aussi
cette violence entre eux alors vous le
savez ceux qui profitent des aides
sociales
et puis d'autres qui donc travaillent
dur et estiment qu'ils n'ont pas les
mêmes idées les mêmes les mêmes
attentions
donc il ya toujours cette espèce
d'octagon isme entre une catégorie et
une autre est bien sûr bain ce débat
fait sortir au grand jour un peu tout
toute cette violence et cette
agressivité qui va donc s'exprimer
envers tout le monde envers les élus
envers les femmes envers envers ceux qui
travaillent envers ceux qui ne
travaillent pas envers les immigrés en
vain voilà donc il faut le prendre comme
une expression mais après nous avons
notre rôle de d'expliquer pour faire un
travail de pédagogie derrière c'est
indispensable parce que le but c'est
quand même de terminer tout ce grand
débat sur une société plus apaisée où
chacun aura eu le sentiment d'avoir été
entendu pas seulement écoutés et donc
qu'on puisse continuer à progresser à
vivre ensemble dans notre pire endurant
ça passe forcément cette société plus
apaisé par ce grand débat ce grand
déballage parfois un défouloir avec ces
violences et tensions entre les citoyens
et les élus
on peut pas nier qu'il des tensions dans
la société française et qui est parfois
les kills âge je pense pas qu'il faille
exagérer ce point là
je reprend la formule de josiane balasko
d'autres jours qui disait on attendait
un grand débat on à questions pour un
champion il faut pas ignorer qu'à une
figure centrale dans la vie publique
française c'est celle du président de la
république et que l'attitude du
président de la république
emmanuel macron depuis le début du
quinquennat et ses nombreuses petites
phrases qui ont émaillé sa fonction et
son gouvernement ont aussi suscité une
réaction et qui a eu un sentiment de
mépris d'arrogance et que ça contribue à
un certain climat
donc on va se baser sur tout ça alors
c'est pas nouveau et dire que ce que
révèle une accro des responsables de de
l'abstentionnisme depuis des années ce
serait mensonger mais il ya un climat
particulier autour de la figure
présidentielle
et cette organisation qui est très
centralisé très centrée sur la personne
du président la république est un piège
pour lui-même qui est autour de lui moi
j'étais d un débat en saône-et-loire à
semaine dernière c'est quand même tout
ça est très bien organisé c'est aussi
une vaste opération de communication
c'est de bonne guerre il faut pas être
dupe faut pas être naïf il faudrait pas
que les français ne retiennent que ça à
la fin il faut que ce soit aussi un beau
débat démocratique
on jugera sur pièces à la fin sur ce qui
en sortira un beau débat démocratique
williams se renier mon idée est quand
même des tensions qui ressurgissent et
notamment envers les élus les
parlementaires ya eu des violences ça a
peut-être franchi un cap me disais ce
week end avec l'instant bilan notamment
du domicile privé du président de
l'assemblée nationale
oui c'est tout à fait inacceptable je
pense qu'il faut il faut que ye
l'apaisement dans le pays qu'on respecte
nos institutions qu'on respecte les élus
qui s'engage s'il ya une vertu à ce
grand débat c'est que c'est là la
possibilité qui est un diagnostic est
aussi partagée sur la situation de notre
pays sur les grands enjeux sur l'état de
nos finances publiques la nécessité de
réindustrialiser notre pays et que ce
diagnostic partagé puis ça après
entraîner vers une politique et cet
entraînement vers une politique c'est
pas de non plus de dire la situation du
pays c'est la faute
tantôt des élus tantôt de la haute
administration je pense qu'on aura
besoin de tout le monde pour redresser
le pays est hélas si ce grand débat
c'est avant cela il
intéressant s'il amène des citoyens qui
s'étaient éloignés du débat politique du
champ politique à s'investir dans le
débat public et à prendre des
responsabilités parce que critiquer
c'est facile après agir c'est plus
compliqué et un gilet jaune qui se
rencontrent je voudrais qu'on aille en
salle des conférences peut-être puisque
jacques mézard votre ancien collègue
sénateur et ancien ministre a donc été
choisi par emmanuel macron pour siéger
au conseil constitutionnel d'ailleurs au
micro-ondes thème traduit on va
peut-être écouté l sa réaction tout de
suite oui jacques mézard vous apprêtez
donc à faire et bien votre entrée au
conseil constitutionnel ce n'est pas
encore validé mais quelle voix
voulez-vous faire entendre par amis et
bien les sages ce que vous voulez faire
entendre celle des territoires
je rappelle que c'était là votre
ministère écoutez d'abord je crois que
je vais essayer d'utiliser le mieux
possible la double expérience qui est la
mienne celle d'un juriste puisque j'ai
exercé la profession d'avocat pendant 37
ans que j'ai été à l'université de paris
1 comme un étudiant et enseignant
pendant 11 ans et que je suis
parlementaire sénateur depuis 2008 donc
je pense que cette double expérience à
la fois de juristes et puis l'homme de
terrain d'élu local
connaissant les territoires et aussi
avec une expérience parlementaire c est
ensemble que d'expérience que je vais
utiliser au sein du conseil
constitionnel après le passage en
commission va ce n'est pas encore fait
bien sûr va être auditionné tout d'abord
si d'importants de faire entendre la
voix des territoires dans le contexte
actuel on sait pour vous c'était très
important
vous aviez même averti l'exécutif pour
dire combien il fallait entend faire
entendre cette voix des territoires
t aujourd'hui le conseil constitutionnel
avec les questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité est très à l'écouté
de l'ensemble des citoyens
je crois pas qu'il faille faire de
clivage entre les territoires ce sont
des gens qui habitent dans ces
territoires et l'intérêt de l'évolution
du conseil constitutionnel avec les
questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité
c'est davantage de proximité c'est un
moyen pour le citoyen de saisir
directement le conseil constitutionnel
par rapport à l'activité législative aux
lois et donc à ce niveau là
effectivement je pense que des
expériences diverses sont utiles au sein
du conseil constitutionnel d'ailleurs
vous allez faire et bien votre entrée
sans doute avec alain juppé qui ce matin
10 ses adieux à bordeaux il a notamment
dit également ne plus vouloir travailler
dans un que vouloir travailler dans un
climat plus serein il regrette les
violences du débat actuel
la stigmatisation des élites à ce que
vous le rejoignez bien dans ce qu'il dit
comment ne pas condamner les violences
nous avons la chance de vivre dans une
démocratie c'est pas le cas de tous les
pays du monde dans une démocratie
représentative où le droit de vote
existe ou la liberté d'expression existe
il est tout à fait déplorable de sombrer
dans une violence qui devient assez
systématique notamment à l'égard des
hommes politiques et des élites bien sûr
mais mais que que veulent dire
d'ailleurs que veut dire ce mot il y a
bien sûr des gens qui sont dans la
difficulté
bien sûr des territoires plus fragiles
mais il faut aussi se rendre compte de
la chance je les dis que nous avons de
vivre dans un pays comme la france on ya
des efforts à faire il ya certainement
des choses à améliorer mais il faut le
faire dans le respect des règles
démocratiques
merci jacques mézard un tout dernier mot
peut-être sur une critique qu'il ya eu
qu'il n'y ait pas plus de femmes lors de
cette association de nomination il y à
des femmes au conseil constitutionnel à
il s'agissait de remplir en fait ce sont
trois hommes qui ont été remplacés par
trois hommes
mais il n'a pas été et toucher à
l'équilibré existant au sein du conseil
constitutionnel et c'est important
merci beaucoup jacques mézard d'avoir
répondu à mes questions merci au premier
ce radar philippe qui vient d'arriver au
sénat pour la séance de questions
d'actualité c'est dans un tout petit
quart d'heure à présent sur le jura ça
vous fait réagir cette nomination de
jacques mézard au conseil
constitutionnel non moi je suis tout à
fait heureux pour ceux qui vont entrer
concédé chainel je suis très heureux de
voir que dans ce pays la sagesse et et
masculine la maison est bien gardé et
pas une femme
voilà donc on est dans une démocratie
mais un peu de parité ça ferait pas de
mal alors chacun choisit son candidat
il se trouve que ces trois hommes c'est
pas de chance pour les femmes à lui
était choisi le maire de bordeaux pour
siéger au conseil constitutionnel par
richard ferrand le président de
l'assemblée nationale
ce matin le maire de bordeaux était ému
aux larmes regardez ce reportage de ses
fans à magnan après 19 ans de vie
commune
il ne pouvait qu'avoir des larmes au
moment de la séparation entre alain
juppé et la mairie de bordeaux quittait
cet hôtel de ville cette fois ci le
moulin gré et pour moi évidemment un
crève coeur
comme vous le savez j'ai accepté la
proposition de monsieur richard ferrand
président de l'assemblée nationale
devenons mai au conseil constitutionnel
c'est pour moi un honneur et je l'en
remercie
happé par le conseil constitutionnel
alain juppé s'offrent une sortie par la
grande porte
une nomination qu'il doit au président
de l'assemblée nationale
preuve supplémentaire sur la relation
cordiale qu'entretient alain juppé avec
la république en marche
multi clamer ses affinités sur fond
d'élections européennes crois qu'il
entendait plutôt continuer à bordeaux en
toute indépendance d'esprit et au
conseil constitutionnel de toute façon
il sera hors champ de politique
partisane
donc je n'y vois pas un dessin de
politique partisane y compris la part de
la majorité puisque à part du monde
entre au conseil constitutionnel je ne
peux soutenir aux européennes
une l'histoire marche est née une liste
lr autres nommés au conseil
constitutionnel les sénateurs jacques
mézard et françois piller désigné par le
président de la république et par le
président du sénat on a je trouve avec
alain juppé avec jacques mézard avec
seafrance woippy les trois hommes qui
sont très différents mais trois valeurs
sûres je crois pour le conseil
constitutionnel je suis heureux
d'ailleurs qui est deux sénateurs mais
que aussi avec alain juppé on portera je
croise une forme de territoriale isme
les trois hommes devront néanmoins
attendre l'approbation des commissions
des lois du parlement pour confirmer
leur entrée en fonctions en attendant la
séance de questions d'actualité
françoise cartron les nombreux bordelais
la surprise est totale jeu je crois
aussi que les réactions ce matin de tous
les bordelais bordelaise disent qu' il
ne s'y attendait pas du tout puisque
alain juppé données plutôt des signes
d'être dans une démarche de de
renouvellement et de et de pré campagne
même si moi j'avais un avis différent
parce que depuis le début de l'épisode
des gilet jaune qui a mis bordeaux
vraiment sur le devant de la scène
on a eu plusieurs réunions avec alain
juppé et alain juppé con que j'ai
toujours vu combatif
quelquefois très ferme autres je les
trouvais atteint le psychologique mans
et je dirais d'une façon sensible il ne
supportait pas m'aimer d'une façon
émotive de voir sa ville comme ça
défigurée pour lui c'était y prenez ça
comme une attaque personnelle avec
derrière ce qui était portée c'était un
sentiment d'impuissance à face à ce
mouvement des légendes on a un sentiment
de mes connaissances puisque ce que
enfin quand on analyse les gie les
jeunes venaient des territoires ruraux
de la gironde et ciblée bordeaux comme
la ville des nantis des privilégiés
et voilà et derrière aussi quelque part
alain juppé et il a souligné ya encore
une dizaine de jours deux verges à
pinggu raw en disant je ne
on ne peut pas dire ça c'est une
mauvaise image de la ville 17 % de la
population est en situation difficile à
bordeaux jamais voulu j'ai voulu faire
une ville ambitieuse pour que elle
bénéficie aux territoires ruraux
derrière et qu'elles rayonnent un petit
peu et je pense à cet échec l'an pour
lui voilà je crois que pour lui
psychologiquement ça a été quelque chose
qu'il a vécue de façon très difficile et
je pense que il n'avait pas l'idée il
était sans doute il ya deux mois dans
une perspective de peut-être repartir
dans un nouveau mandat et là il a vécu
ça comme une injustice
il fera partie des questions d'actualité
cet après-midi sur les 20 qu'a dit quand
votre collectionneurs recentrer ce qui
va interpeller et bien leur en une et
sur le rétablissement justement de
l'ordre républicain
après ce mouvement des gilets jaunes il
ya encore de nombreuses attentes de la
part des élus on voit bien sûr il faut
que que l'ordre républicain soit soit
respectée non ce pays que la liberté de
circulation que voilà le respect des dd
il eu soin soit en vigueur donc on
attend que ces épisodes de dégradation
de nos centres villes de grandes villes
comme de villes de plus petite taille
ces activités de économique de ces
centres vie qui sont quand même perturbé
depuis toutes ces semaines c'est un
manque à gagner qui considère enfin et
donc il faut à la fois le rétablissement
de l'ordre et le rétablissement de la
vie économique dans ce pays où il ya le
grand débat qui est là que ceux qui ont
des choses à dire s'exprime dans ce
cadre formel je pense qu'il faut quitter
les les manifestations et surtout les
dégradations dans les manifestations qui
sont devenues insupportables sur le
territoire national et puis aussi sur
l'image de la france à l'intervention
ce qui est aussi un effet tout à fait
négatifs ces mouvements je le disais le
soutien dans l'opinion commence un peu à
ça fait bien au pourtant il est toujours
présent avec chaque samedi
rythmé par de nouveaux incidents de
nouvelles manifestations jérôme durain
ce grand débat ça ne permet pas
finalement bien de sortir de ce
mouvement on est on est quand même face
à un échec
la gestion de cette de cette phase long
de cette séquence longue on n'aurait
jamais dû avoir ce mouvement ça a été
mal gérée depuis le début il ya eu des
erreurs politiques
un défaut d' écoutes qui est sans doute
lié à la structuration du mouvement
marché de la majorité présidentielle
avec des gens qui sont trop peu
implantées dans les territoires est une
forme d'arrogance en tout cas telle
qu'elle est vécue par les parlers gilet
jaune
donc il faut retrouver de la concorde il
faut retrouver l'ordre public 1 il faut
qu'on regarde vers le vers le haut
maintenant qu'on se trompe tous vers le
haut avec sans doute des propositions
qui sont en phase axe avec ce que j'en
attendais pouvoir d'achat évidemment la
question fiscale etc pas de table il n'y
a pas de tabou questions vont débuter
dans un instant avant cela dans un
agrément le porte-parole du gouvernement
est à votre micro est à notre ami guy
benjamin griveaux tout d'abord via votre
réaction à la nomination d'alain juppé
qui va donc faire son entrée au conseil
constitutionnel que représente-t-il pour
vous et c'est un homme politique d'état
qui arrive ainsi au conseil
constitutionnel d'abord c'est un homme
politique que les français connaissent
bien ils le connaissent depuis longtemps
je crois qu'il a su démontrer dans sa
longue carrière politique avec des
responsabilités à la fois national et
local qu'il était un homme d'état qu'il
était un humaniste qu'il était adapté à
des principes qui fondent la république
que sont les libertés publiques le
respect d'autrui
et puis aussi un certain sens de la
mesure dont je crois nous avons bien
besoin dans la période est donc moi je
suis y est très heureux qu'il ait
accepté cette proposition qui a été
faite par le président de l'assemblée
nationale voyez ils sont pas issus du
même bord politique
ils n'ont pas la même histoire politique
et c'est aussi je crois un bon signal
envoyé dans cette période c'était une
immense surprise de le voir quitter
notamment sa ville de bordeaux pour
laquelle il a énormément fait il a
expliqué aussi par là
violence du climat actuel est ce que
vous le rejoignez bien dans le fait
qu'il est notamment la stigmatisation
des élites
il ya beaucoup de violence dans la
société actuellement dans la société
française dans la société politique et
je suis sûr que comme juges
constitutionnels il sera aussi trouver
les mots pour apaiser cette part de
violence qui est inhérente à la société
française mais qui aujourd'hui connaît
des relents particulièrement puissant
dans l'opinion
c'est aussi cela le rôle du juge
conditionnel c'est d'être au dessus
c'est d'être en dehors du temps présent
et puis de regarder un peu à l'horizon
et d'être le gardien du temple et il
sera un des gardiens du temps un tout
petit mot sur le fait qu'il y à aussi
bien anciens collègues du gouvernement
qui va leur conseil constitutionnel
jacques mézard actuellement à sénateurs
rdse
je suis très heureux pour lui parce que
d'abord c'est un homme c'est un homme de
loi
jacques mézard et il est toujours bon
d'avoir des hommes de loi la notion
d'information de la juge constitutionnel
est avocat de formation
c'est quelqu'un mais qui en a eu de
nombreux débats passionnants pendant la
campagne quand on a bâti le projet
présidentiel pour le candidat à l'époque
emmanuel macron moi je suis très heureux
pour lui à titre bien au temps politique
qu'amicale et personnelle bien merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu aux questions
de public sénat
je voulais donc rejoindre la séance qui
va commencer d'un instant à l'autre et
nous allons nous rejoindre justement
alexandre poussard depuis la tribune de
presse de l'hémicycle pour l'ordre du
jour de cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
hewitt a mais cette séance de questions
d'actualité va être placée sous le signe
de la violence dans la société française
et notamment de d'actes antisémites avec
un chiffre alarmant la hausse de 74% des
actes antisémites en france en 2018 une
haine antisémite que toute la classe
politique a condamné à l'unanimité
et je rappelle que le week-end dernier
l'image de simone veil a été barrée
d'une croix gammée et que l'arbre dylan
halimi assassiné en 2006 par le gang des
barbares a été profanée et c'est aussi
la communauté catholique qui a été
attaquée avec en une semaine cinq
églises qui ont été dégradés durant deux
c'est durant ces questions il y aura
des questions sur la violence mais cette
fois ci dans les manifestations des
gilet jaune et le sénateur centriste
olivier cadic va interpeller le ministre
de l'intérieur christophe castaner pour
lui demander quand va-t-il rétablir
l'ordre républicain alors que le
week-end dernier la violence a franchi
un cap et qu'un véhicule militaire de
l'opération antiterroriste sentinelles a
été incendié et puis hier le boxeur
christophe dettinger qui avait frappé
des deux gendarmes début janvier a été
condamné à un an de prison ferme
depuis le début du monde des jeunes pour
vous donner un chiffre il y a eu 1800
condamnation
la clause vient de sonner c'est le début
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
questions retransmises sur public sénat
sur notre site internet au nom du bureau
du sénat chacun veillera à la courtoisie
au respect des uns et les autres et au
respect du temps c'est donne la parole à
notre collègue dominique de legge pour
le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues
cette semaine des violences à l'encontre
des juifs et la promotion de la barbarie
navy ont marqué l'actualité provoquant
la conspiration et l'adie nation de tous
ces actes vienne à la suite de
profanations d'édifices catholique 7 ont
été recensés la première semaine de
février
tout se passe comme si à la crise
sociale à la crise territoriale
s'ajoutait une crise encore plus grave
plus grave parce que c'est celle du
coeur qui touche à l'essence même de
notre humanité à l'intimité de chacun de
nous à notre histoire personnelle et
collective
la république parce qu'elle est laïque
se doit de garantir à tous qu'ils
croient ou qu'ils ne croient pas à une
vie et à une des convictions
spirituelles leur est grave
monsieur le premier ministre que
resterait-il d'une société où tout ce
qui relève de la pensée de la
spiritualité ne serait pas garantie
quelles dispositions comptez vous
prendre pour que chaque citoyen puisse
aspirer à une spiritualité apaisées et
que la france reste le pays de la
liberté des lumières et ne deviennent
pas celui de la barbarie et de
l'obscurantisme
ne pensez vous pas que le moment est
venu de nommer les fauteurs de trouble
jeu vont pour vous répondre
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre le premier
ministre et la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur vous
m'interrogez sur la multiplication des
actes antisémites sur la multiplication
des actes de profanation d'un certain
nombre de lieux de culte catholiques ou
juifs sur le climat à nauséabond qui se
développe dans notre pays
vous me posez cette question avec
beaucoup de gravité en indiquant votre
indignation et en indiquant que vous ne
pouvez pas vous contenter de cette
indignation et que vous souhaitez qu'en
réponse à ces actes des politiques
publiques des réactions effective puisse
avoir lieu je voudrais monsieur le
sénateur vous assurer que nous sommes de
ce point de vue parfaitement en ligne
car oui depuis quelques semaines oh
malheureusement ces actes ne date pas
d'il ya quelques semaines ils ne se sont
jamais complètement arrêtée dans notre
pays mais enfin depuis quelques semaines
nous constatons une multiplication de
ces actes d actes antisémites
inacceptable répugnant qui prennent des
formes extrêmement variés des menaces
contre les personnes des tags des
attaques contre les symboles
vous avez vu comme moi je sais que nous
aurons l'occasion au cours de cette
séance de question d'évoquer ce sujet la
tap fait à la mémoire d'ilan halimi à
sainte geneviève des bois
face à cette multiplication d'actes
antisémites ou anti catholique
s'agissant des églises et des cimetières
vous faites bien monsieur le sénateur de
rappeler que la république respecte le
sacré car en france dans notre
république nous avons le droit de croire
ou de ne pas croire
et lorsque nous croyons nous devons être
respectée parce que nous croyons
toujours en france est toujours sous la
république
on a respecté les églises les cimetières
les lieux de culte et il est impératif
de rappeler qu'il doit toujours en être
ainsi
ça ne suffit pas de le dire j'en ai
parfaitement conscience que seul
sénateur
mais vous savez comme moi que le jour où
nous ne le dirons plus alors tout serait
perdu nous devons donc rappelé la norme
la norme c'est qu'en france on respecte
les lieux sacrés symboles de la
république
les lieux de culte les lieux où reposent
les morts nous leur devons le respect
c'est un impératif qui s'impose à tous
et qu'il convient systématiquement de
rappeler mais ça ne suffit pas vous avez
raison il faut aller plus loin c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons avec le
gouvernement mais au fond ces sujets
s'inscrivent dans une ligne d'action
dans une dans un continuum d'action nous
avons souhaité agir sur plusieurs
domaines en matière en matière d'abord
de formation
car aussi scandaleux ces actes
antisémites ou anti culturel si j'ose
dire puisse-t-il nous paraître
nous devons faire en sorte qu'ils soient
mieux déceler qu'il soit mieux
retranscrit par les forces de l'ordre
qu'ils puissent être faire l'objet
d'instructions plus complète par les
services de la justice et de sanctions
plus sévères à mon sens par la
magistrature ses efforts de formation
nous avons engagé
chez les forces de police et les forces
de gendarmerie auprès des magistrats ils
sont indispensables
les efforts d'éducation aussi et c'est
un combat anciens c'est un combat
permanent est un combat difficile qu'il
faut livrer contre l'obscurantisme
contre l'ignorance et parfois contre eux
c'est peu de dire l'obscurantisme c'est
presque encore encore bienveillant nous
devons livrer ce combat à l'école
partout et nous savons qu'il est
difficile je me souviens monsieur le
président que l'expression hussard noir
désigné autant la couleur qui revêtait
les instituteurs que la logique de
combat qui les inspire est le combat
contre l'obscurantisme il faut que nous
retrouvions d'une certaine façon cette
logique est que nous livrions absolument
partout et en tout lieu
ce combat contre l'obscurantisme contre
la haine contre les préjugés contre la
bêtise la plus crasse contre la
méchanceté la plus vive éducation
formation dénonciation et sanctions
c'est indispensable sanction sévère car
les faits sont inacceptables
transformation de notre droit nous
aurons l'occasion au cours de l'année
2019 de soumettre et d'étudier avec
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat des
dispositions législatives qui
permettront de faire évoluer le droit
notamment la responsabilité de ceux qui
gèrent les réseaux sociaux afin qu' il
ne puisse se contenter de dire nous ne
sommes pas des éditeurs
nous sommes au fond des hébergeurs
nous ne sommes pas responsables de ce
qui se dit sur nos réseaux c'est
inacceptable
nous ne pouvons pas l'accepter il nous
faut donc changer le droit à changer le
droit communautaire
nous avons engagé cette discussion avec
nos partenaires et sans attendre changer
le droit national c'est ce que nous
ferons au cours de l'année 2019
et puis nous devons nommer tous ceux qui
commettent ces actes
tous ceux qui collectent ces actes
antisémites avec eux les vieilles
racines de l'antisémitisme français et
les nouvelles avec ce cet antisémitisme
qui n'a jamais été je le dis car ce
serait trop simple l'apanage d'une
famille politique mais qui s'est
déployée dans de très nombreux dans de
très nombreuses familles politiques dans
de très nombreux aspects de la société
française parfois très vivement parfois
très discrètement l'antisémitisme aussi
résurgent et qui se développe liés aux
amalgames du conflit israélo-palestinien
au développement d'un radics d'une
radicalisation d'un radicalisme
islamiste
tous ces éléments toutes ses
constituantes de l'antisémitisme qui se
développe dans notre pays doivent être
combattus doivent être nommés avec une
indéfectible détermination je voudrais
assurer le sénat que je suis attaché à
cette cause de l'indéfectible
détermination de l'ensemble des membres
du gouvernement sur ce sujet merci
monsieur le premier menu de lège
[Applaudissements]
que de lège merci monsieur le premier
ministre de cette réponse mais je crois
et vous l'avez souligné qu'il faut avoir
le courage de nommer les auteurs les
auteurs on les connaît c'est l'extrême
gauche anti sioniste c'est l'islam
radical qui va imposer la charia et
celle avis c'est l'extrême droite qui
regrette cette période de la france
alors permettez-moi de vous inviter très
respectueusement à méditer cette belle
phrase d'albert camus
mal nommer les choses c'est ajouter du
malheur au monde
merci la parole est maintenant leur
collègue olivier cadic pour le groupe de
l'union centriste avait la parole mon
cher collègue
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur mise en intérieur permettez moi
tout d'abord d'exprimer au nom du groupe
union centriste notre plus vive
indignation vis-à-vis des récentes
profanation et inscriptions antisémites
qui ont notamment visé des personnalités
emblématiques tels que simone veil ou
ilan halimi
comme l'a rappelé monsieur premier
ministre révulsée affligé nous affichons
notre solidarité vis-à-vis de la
communauté juive et nous condamnons
également avec force les insupportables
profanation de tous les lieux de culte
qui se multiplient dans les églises
synagogues et mosquées
cela doit cesser sans faire d'amalgamé
il n'échappe à personne que le mouvement
des gilet jaune est aussi générateur
d'appels à la haine
chaque samedi ces défilés entretiennent
en france un climat nauséabond fait de
populisme et d' antiparlementarisme
et pourtant il ne s'agit plus que d'une
poignée de français dont une partie
d'extrémistes et qui ne représentent
qu'eux mêmes
parce que dans une démocratie les
représentants doivent être élus dois je
le rappeler ici vous recevez comme moi
chers collègues des courriers insensé
qui nous appelle entre autres à la
destitution du président macron au
diable l'état de droit et le résultat
des élections
peu importe aussi les conséquences
économiques et les salariés mis au
chômage technique
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir monsieur le
ministre que les commerçants expriment
de plus en plus fort leur ras-le-bol
quand ils ne descendent pas eux aussi
dans la rue comme à toulouse une
exaspération qui gagne désormais les
élus municipaux qui sollicitent le
gouvernement pour obtenir une
indemnisation pour les villes touchées
par les dégradations
à l'issue des manifestations l'agitation
de rue doit cesser s'ils veulent
manifester très bien mais selon les
règles républicaines pas n'importe où
pas n'importe comment
le mandat des manuels ma tronche
s'achèvera dans 166 semaine
au train où vont les choses peut-on
imaginer qu'il y aura un acte 166 des
gilet jaune
alors monsieur le ministre ma question
est simple quand comptez-vous faire
rétablir l'ordre républicain jour la
série quand vous répondre parole
monsieur le secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur laurent
nous neige avaient la parole monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur cadic vous avez raison de
souligner effectivement que le mouvement
dit du gilet jaune a pris une tournure
qui se résume maintenant à des
manifestations de voie publique
tous les samedis après midi et qui dans
bon nombre de villes dégénèrent parfois
au début de la manifestation
parfois la fin de la manifestation à
caen jdg l'air c'est un euphémisme c'est
extrêmement violent donc quelques
centaines d'individus dans chaque site
s'en prennent de manière extrêmement
violente à nos institutions aux mairies
aux préfectures aux forces de l'ordre
aux parlementaires de manière
extrêmement violente agressive et ça
nous conduit partout en france a déployé
pour chaque manifestation des
dispositifs policiers
convenez que ce mouvement il est
totalement inédit nous n'avons pas connu
ça depuis plusieurs dizaines d'années
des manifestations qui ne sont jamais
déclarer une une infiltration et vous
avez raison de le souligner par les
milieux ultra gauche par les milieux
ultra droite parfois et puis par des
gilets jaunes qui se sont radicalisés et
qui sur la voie publique quand ils
manifestent et fondé générer ces
manifestations ne représente plus
maintenant que même et vous avez raison
de le souligner face à ce mouvement et
j'étais encore hier soir à dijon avec
des fonctionnaires de police des
militaires de la gendarmerie nationale
pour saluer leur courage leur abnégation
pour y faire face face à ce mouvement
avec christophe castaner tous les samedi
nous déployons les effectifs de voie
publique qui encadrent ces
manifestations et qui interviennent
chaque fois qu'elle dégénère pour
interpeller mettre un terme à ces
exactions
nous avons au total depuis le 17
novembre interpellé huit mille quatre
cents personnes se sont 7500 en garde à
vue 1800 personnes ont été condamnées et
comptait bien sur notre détermination
pour poursuivre cette action sur la voie
publique et puis ces investigations
judiciaires qui sont menées ensuite et
qui permet de confondre de nombreux
auteurs tous les jours sont interpellés
des casseurs qui sont confondus
plusieurs jours plusieurs semaines après
grâce à nos investigations judiciaires
croyez bien que nous sommes totalement
déterminés pour y mettre un terme et que
nous attendons aussi beaucoup de
dispositions législatives que nous
souhaitons voir adopter et qui vous
permettront d'écarter les individus
casseurs des manifestations je vous
remercie de votre attention
si le chul min la parole est à notre
collègue bernard but pour le groupe de
la république en marche mon cher
collègue
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics
comme annoncé par le premier ministre en
septembre dernier l'impôt sur le revenu
est prélevé à la source depuis le 1er
janvier 2019 réformes longtemps annoncée
demandé est attendu par les
contribuables n'est jamais mise en
oeuvre le prélèvement à la source est
aujourd'hui soutenue par les trois
quarts des françaises et des français
vous avez fait monsieur le secrétaire
d'état le pari de l'intelligence
collective
le pari que les français comprennent des
avantages d'un paiement en temps réel de
l'impôt sur le revenu pour leur
quotidien et la gestion de leur budget
le pari que les entreprises françaises
s'organiserait en temps et en heure pour
que ce prélèvement soit effectif et bien
compris sur les fiches de paye de leurs
salariés comme par exemple mentionné
pour informations sur les dernières
fiches de paye de 2018
quel serait le salaire versé après le
prélèvement à la source
le pari que les 5 millions de foyers
bénéficiant d'un crédit d'impôt pour
services à la personne ou pour frais de
garde d'enfants perçoivent ce crédit
d'impôt sous forme d'averses de 60%
versée dès le 15 janvier et
correspondant au crédit ou la réduction
d'impôt de l'année précédente avant le
versement de la totalité à l'été 2010 9
enfin le pari que votre ministère et les
fonctionnaires de votre administration
déploierez pendant plusieurs mois et le
temps qu'il faudrait des moyens de
communication d'information et
d'accompagnement à la hauteur de cet
enjeu
ce succès montre la préparation de la
réforme avant l'été dernier un sondage
montrait que les deux tiers des français
payant l'impôt sur le revenu se sentait
bien informée ce succès montre aussi que
les cassandre en tout genre prend à
souhaiter l'échec du gouvernement plutôt
que la réussite collective se sont
trompés
on a parlé au sénat d'une usine à gaz
une proposition de loi pour retarder
encore la réforme a même été déposé
alors monsieur le secrétaire d'état si
la mise en oeuvre du prélèvement à la
source est d'ores et déjà un succès ce
succès nous le devons à la fois aux
entreprises et aux collecteurs il faut
maintenant transformer l'essai pouvez
vous nous expliquer les mesures qui
seront prises pour assurer durant cette
année 2010 9 l'accompagnement des
entreprises quels sont les moyens mis en
oeuvre pour à notre administration pour
répondre aux questions des contribuables
ne manqueront pas se poser est donc
passé maintenant on me le dire 19la
prend le relais pour vos réponses et au
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'action lé plus grand public
je lui dis merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur ben oui vous avez
raison monsieur le sénateur de rappeler
que la mise en oeuvre du prélèvement la
source c'est une bonne réforme c'est une
informe qui réussit les chiffres sont
éloquents
plusieurs dizaines de millions de titres
de revenu ont été traités il n'y a aucun
bug systémique et l'ensemble des
contribuables payent désormais un impôt
contemporain ce qui est là l'objectif
principal puisque 7 millions de
contribuables dans notre pays voient
leur revenu varier de plus ou moins 30 %
chaque année avec dans le système ancien
la nécessité de payer un impôt qui ne
correspondaient plus en termes de
niveaux au niveau réel de leurs revenus
alors qu'aujourd'hui le montant de
l'impôt payé chaque mois s'adaptera aux
revenus des contribuables des foyers
fiscaux de manière à ce qu'ils soient
justes et qu'il soit aussi plus
soutenable nous avons mené cette réforme
pour les contribuables
nous l'avons menée avec les agents et
nous avons effectivement formé
quarante mille agents des finances
publiques pour mettre en oeuvre le
prélèvement la source et notamment
apporter des réponses aux contribuables
comme aux entreprises soit dans les
perceptions soit via internet soit du
fait de la mise en place d'une
plateforme téléphonique avec 14 centres
d'appels et environ 1000 agents des
finances publiques formés pour répondre
à l'ensemble des questions
nous avons aussi travaillé avec les
sociétés éditrices de bulletins de paye
de tout au long de l'année 2018 pour
faire en sorte que la mise en oeuvre
techniquement soit réussie
et faire en sorte aussi que dans
l'immense majorité des cas pour les
entreprises ce soit une opération de
maintenance des logiciels de déclaration
sociale nominative plutôt qu'un
investissement nouveau de manière à en
diminuer le coût à chaque fois que cela
était possible et aussi fortement que
possible tout au long de l'année qui
vient
nos équipes vont rester mobilisés
mobilisés pour répondre aux
contribuables mobilisés pour travailler
à l'avenir à compte encore analysé
autant que possible les crédits d'impôt
et nous allons évidemment comme nous
nous étions engagés devant le sénat à
l'occasion la loi sur de l'examen de la
loi sur la confiance à faire preuve de
la plus grande bienveillance pour les
entreprises de manière à ne pas
sanctionner les entreprises de bonne foi
merci la parole et notre collègue
olivier léonard pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique social
européen et chacun respectera son temps
de parole monsieur le président mes
chers collègues
cette question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre
lundi 11 février les arbres plantés à
sainte-geneviève-des-bois la mémoire d'
ilan halimi ont été coupées profaner
j'étais maire de cette commune en 2006
quand il a n'a été retrouvé agonisant le
long de cette voie ferrée après 24 jours
de terribles tortures enlevé frappé
brûlé torturé il a un est mort
simplement parce qu'il était juif
personne ne pouvait plus ignorer qu'on
pouvait à nouveau s'en prendre à un juif
en france en pensant s'en prendre à une
famille et une communauté privilégiée
qui n'aurait aucun mal à payer aucun mal
à payer une forte somme d'argent pour
obtenir sa libération
mais la liste mais l'assassinât dylan
avait malheureusement un caractère
annonciateurs car il faut le dire
depuis ce 13 février 2006 mourir en
france parce qu'on est juif n'est
malheureusement plus y est exceptionnel
que cela et il faut le dire les
condamnations de principe ne sont plus
suffisantes
les comme l'écho cérémonies
commémoratives et les minutes de silence
ne peuvent plus être les seules réponses
à l'intolérable
alors je sais que vous allez me dire à
raison que beaucoup de choses sont
initiées pour lutter contre le racisme
et l'antisémitisme
j'étais d'ailleurs avec vous monsieur le
premier ministre à matignon mardi pour
la remise du prix l'analyse et halimi à
des jeunes engagés contre ce fléau
je sais que vous allez me dire à raison
que des actions sont engagées pour la
formation des forces des personnels pour
la formation des enseignants des
policiers des magistrats
je sais que vous allez me dire à raison
qu'il faut s'adapter à la loi ou adapter
la loi plus exactement pour agir plus
sévèrement face aux messages haineux sur
les réseaux sociaux
mais monsieur le premier ministre ne
pensez vous pas que l'enjeu de la
fraternité dans notre pays méritent une
action encore plus résolue des actions
encore plus rapide est encore plus forte
nous savons le rôle de l'éducation pour
répondre à ce défi nous savons aussi
qu'aujourd'hui en 2019 des projets
pédagogiques associatifs ou
institutionnels auprès de la jeunesse ne
sont pas menées faute de moyens ne
pensez-vous pas donc que la gravité de
la situation impose que notre pays
consacrent plus que 6 millions d'euros
par an à la délégation
interministérielle à louis ii contre le
racisme l'antisémitisme l'antisémitisme
et la haine
antienne lgbt qui dispose des seuls
crédits dédiés strictement à cet enjeu
vital pour l'avenir de notre république
monsieur le premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur lundi dernier les
arbres plantés à la mémoire d'ilan
halimi à sainte geneviève des bois ont
été profanées coupé et ils ont donné
lieu à lille une immense émotion partout
en france mais probablement encore plus
chez tous ceux qui au moment du drame
avait été présent et vous étiez de cela
puisque comme vous l'avez dit monsieur
le sénateur vous étiez maire au moment
des faits je veux commencer par dire que
je comprends parfaitement l'émotion que
vous vivez depuis lundi et que vous avez
transcrit dans la question que vous
venez de poser mardi
vous l'avez dit la date avait été fixée
bien avant il nous appartenait de
remettre pour la première fois le prix
ilan halimi
reprenant en cela une initiative qui
était né dans l'essonne une initiative
du conseil départemental du conseil
général de l'époque
une initiative portée à l'époque par son
président jérôme guedj pour essayer de
récompenses et de mobiliser d'encourager
des projets pédagogiques porter dans les
collèges ou dans les lycées est destiné
à faire comprendre la réalité de
l'antisémitisme et à offrir un certain
nombre d'instruments pour lutter contre
ce fléau
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire vous vous en
souvenez peut-être monsieur le sénateur
que face à tous ces coups terribles que
nous prenions face à tous ces actes
antisémites face non pas au
découragement mais à la menace de
lassitude qui gagnait parfois ces
initiatives portées ici par une scène
nationale la par un collège ici par une
association qui mobilisait les jeunes
étaient aussi des messages d'espoir
et vous aurez je crois enfin je crois
qu'on pourra se retrouver monsieur le
sénateur sur le fait que les quatre
projets qui ont été identifiés qui ont
reçu un prix parmi la dizaine centaine
de projets qui ont été portés et est
absolument remarquable
oui il faut former oui il faut éduquer
oui il faut dénoncer
oui il ne faut jamais renoncer
mais c'est un combat long je le sais les
phrases que je prononce
elles ont été prononcées peut-être avec
plus de talent mais pas avec -
détermination par des premiers ministres
avant moi qui se sont pleinement engagés
dans cette lutte contre l'antisémitisme
ce combat monsieur le sénateur c'est un
art d'exécution
c'est un art de détermination c'est un
art d'exécution il doit être mené de
façon systématique
j'ai insisté sur le soutien que nous
devions apporter à ceux qui proposent
l'éducation dans nos écoles dans nos
collèges dans nos lycées le soutien
matériel que nous avions apporté avec le
développement de ces équipes de laïcité
qui viennent au soutien de ceux qui
constatent des actes et qui alors même
qu'ils sont pleins de bonne foi plein de
détermination ne savent pas toujours y
répondre ne savent pas toujours y
répondre nous devons les aider de
nouveaux les accompagner est-ce que
c'est suffisant ça ne sera jamais
suffisant sans doute dans ce combat
difficile
et dans ce combat qui malheureusement ma
part est éternel mais si vous avez et
vous les avez tracé des pistes pour nous
donner de nouveaux instruments dans ce
combat alors monsieur le sénateur je
suis tout à fait prêt à en discuter avec
vous car nous avons besoin de
l'engagement et de l'intelligence de
chacun pour gagner ce combat
merci beaucoup merci
d'abord le tas notre collègue cécile
kirmann pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes avaient
la parole monsieur le président le
sionisme et chers collègues
en décembre dernier le ministre de la
transition écologique nous le disaient
qu'il y aurait plus qu'un gel des tarifs
de l'électricité que le gouvernement
travailler sur des mesures qui
permettraient de ne pas avoir de hausse
ils nous disaient même dans un mois les
tarifs de l'énergie vont baisser je peux
le garantir aux français de 2 à 3%
mais aujourd'hui c'est 6% de hausse des
tarifs qui est annoncé la hausse pouvant
même être plus importante pour le mois
de juin après la mobilité vous allez
créer de nouvelles fractures
territoriales
vous prenez le risque de faire basculer
dans la précarité énergétique de
nouveaux ménages alors qu'ils sont déjà
près de 6 millions dans notre pays vous
demandez encore une fois à nos
concitoyens de payer plus vous leur
demander de payer alors que ces hausses
successives ne sont que leur offre le
reflet de l'échec de la libéralisation
du marché de l'électricité
vous leur demander de se résoudre à
accepter une répercussion sur leur
facture de plus de 100 euros par an
alors que toutes les demandes de
revalorisation du smic d'une véritable
négociation sur les salaires sont
balayées d'un revers de main en ce
moment même osé prix du carburant hausse
des prix alimentaires
osez prix de l'énergie gaz électricité
c'est une véritable politique assumée de
paupérisation de nos concitoyens que
vous menez actuellement monsieur le
ministre quelles dispositions pérenne
allez vous prendre pour endiguer ce
phénomène continue d' augmentation
artificielle du prix de l'électricité
quand accepterez-vous de baisser les
taxes sur ce bien de première nécessité
c'était à tfc de tva csp eu autant de
taxes qui pèsent pour près d'un tiers
dans la facture des ménages de notre
pays
vous l'avez pourtant fait pour adp et
pour les data center dans le cadre de la
préparation du bric site pourquoi ne pas
le faire une bonne fois pour toutes pour
nos concitoyens dans notre pays merci
pour vous répondre la parole et ministre
d'état
maëlys de la transition écologique et
solidaire
il avait la parole monsieur brise d'été
remercie monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice kuperman vous avez
parlé de trois types d'énergie et de
leur prix et de leurs tarifs
concernant les carburants vous le savez
il y avait une forte hausse au mois
d'octobre liée à l'augmentation des prix
du pétrole sur le marché mondial
nous avons décidé alors que par ailleurs
un mouvement de protestation important
s'est élevé à partir de cela mais je
crois que nous pourrions être d'accord
sur le fait que la revendication portait
bien au delà de cette question et
d'ailleurs les prix des carburants entre
temps ont rebaissé parce que les prix du
pétrole sur le marché mondial ont baissé
nous avons pris d'ailleurs d'autres
mesures mais nous avons tenu notre
engagement qui était de stopper la
trajectoire sur la taxe carbone et la
trajectoire de rattrapage diesel essence
qui était motivée par des considérations
de santé publique ainsi que la taxation
du gazole non routier
donc cet engagement a été pris à la fin
de l'année 2018
même si les prix du pétrole entre temps
au bc cet engagement a été tenu
vous avez parlé des tarifs du gaz je
pense que voulait parler des tarifs du
gaz en tout cas moi j'avais dit que les
tarifs du gaz baisserait au 1er janvier
les tarifs du gaz ont bien baissé de 2%
au 1er janvier 2019 pour ce qui concerne
les tarifs régulés
enfin les tarifs de l'électricité vous
le savez sans doute madame la sénatrice
le mode de calcul des tarifs régulés et
fixées par la loi
nous appliquons la loi et la loi dit
les tarifs doivent recouper les coûts de
production les coûts de production ont
augmenté les tarifs augmentent si nous
ne le faisons pas et bien cette année
vous le savez très bien cela sera
répercutée encore plus fort l'année
prochaine
nous avons pris un engagement pas de
hausse des tarifs de l'électricité
pendant l'hiver
et donc nous tenons cet engagement pour
que cette hausse ne s'applique pas
pendant les périodes où nos compatriotes
se chauffent quelques secondes du
carbone monsieur mini jeux vous
interroger sur la suppression de taxes
vous me répondez sur les prix
d'électricité vous me parlez d'augmenter
les prix à l'été et pas à l'hiver mais
je crois que au mois de novembre
prochain
l'hiver sera quand même rude et
l'augmentation de cet été sera répercuté
sur les factures l'hiver prochain pour
nos concitoyens vous ne réglez pas la
question du pouvoir d'achat dans notre
pays merci la parole est maintenant
notre collègue yves daudigny pour le
groupe socialiste et républicain vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président à mon tour monsieur le premier
ministre
parce que le sujet est grave d'insister
les rues de paris noirci d'expression
antisémite
des croix gammées gamme sur les
portraits de simone veil you done
badigeonnez sur la devanture du
restaurant les arbres plantés en hommage
à ilan halimi ce jeune homme enlevé
séquestré et torturé à mort parce qu'il
était juif ciller l'hydre toujours rené
ces actes du singulière lâcheté révèle
un antisémitisme qui ne s'estompe pas
qui restent qui mute un antisémitisme
qui portent atteinte à la communauté
nationale qui percute nos valeurs
républicaines qui questionnent notre
devoir de mémoire
un antisémitisme désinhibés par internet
et des réseaux sociaux sur lesquels
prospèrent les mythes complotistes des
slogans tout droit sortie des poubelles
de l'histoire
un insondable une insondable passion
pour la haine les actes et menaces
antisémites ont crû de 74 % l'an dernier
ils traduisent une réalité vécue
ressenti tous les jours par de nombreux
français qui subissent des injures des
violences en raison de leur kippa ou de
leur patronyme dans la rue dans les
transports sur internet à l'école ou
devant leur lieu de culte
nous ne pouvons accepter que nos
compatriotes de religion ou de culture
juive ne puissent vivre en sécurité
simplement pour ce qu'ils sont
à ceux qui se croient à perméable
rappelons les mots de frantz fanon
quand vous entendez dire du mal des
juifs dresser l'oreille on parle de vous
monsieur le ministre monsieur le premier
ministre
quelles mesures le gouvernement entend
t-il développé pour lutter contre cet
antisémitisme qui sème la honte et
l'horreur dans la république au droit
dans au pays des droits de l'homme
cette lutte nécessite l'engagement de
toutes et de tous et nous serons aux
côtés de toutes celles et tous ceux qui
s'y engageront je vous remercie pour
vous répondre
la parole de coquetterie dans les cas
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur laurent du neuf et la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur le premier ministre tout à
l'heure vous a expliqué le contexte du
plan de lutte contre l'antisémitisme et
contre le racisme d'une manière générale
que nous mettons en oeuvre depuis 2018
2020 il ya toute une série de mesures
permettez moi d'en citer une précisément
ce qui est vous avez cité le contenu des
propos haineux que l'on trouve sur les
réseaux sociaux
je veux ici dire que nous sommes
extrêmement attentifs à ces contenus
c'est une politique forte que nous
menons nous avons une plateforme qui
s'appelle la plateforme pharos qui nous
permet de détecter ces contenus et de
demander aux fournisseurs d'accès à
internet de procéder à des retraits et
nous procédons également à des
investigations judiciaires longues qui
nous permettent de confondre les auteurs
et il y a de ce fait de nombreuses
condamnations
le premier ministre cité tout à l'heure
une expérimentation qui a mené à
marseille qui est très intéressante qui
permet de former des enquêteurs de
former des magistrats de pouvoir mieux
caractériser cette circonstance
aggravante et odieuse qui est le
caractère antisémite d'une infraction et
nous poursuivons l'ensemble de ces
mesures qui portent sur toute une
panoplie d'actions qui sont menées avec
beaucoup de détermination qui touche
aussi au champ éducatif et bien
évidemment nous allons le poursuivre
mais je voudrais aussi dire et vous
rassurer sur le fait que le ministère de
l'intérieur travaille en lien très
étroit avec les cultes et d'ailleurs
avec l'ensemble des cultes y compris
d'ailleurs le culte catholique depuis
maintenant 2015
nous avons des relations étroites avec
les responsables des cultes et notamment
des lieux
culte de manière à pouvoir sécuriser
physiquement les cérémonies les plus
importantes les lieux de manifestations
les plus importants et les fêtes les
plus importantes et nous menons là
encore cette action de manière
extrêmement résolue à déterminer et ce
sont l'ensemble des fonctionnaires de
police et de gendarmerie qui sont
sensibilisés comme le rappelait à
l'instant le premier ministre dans ce
pays
et j'ajoute pour terminer d'ailleurs que
comme vous le savez nous engageons une
politique d' aides à l'investissement
pour tous les dispositifs de
sécurisation qui sont mis en place pour
tous les cultes d'ailleurs y compris
bien sûr le culte juif et le culte
catholique
nous avons au titre du fonds
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquance une politique très active de
soutien à la sécurisation de ces lieux
qu'il convient effectivement de protéger
à tout prix
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
notre collègue jean pierre decool pour
le groupe les indépendants avaient la
parole c'est le président de celui
d'istres mes chers collègues en
liminaire je précise qu'il n'y a ni
provocation ni perfidie dans ma question
d'un simple coup de téléphone
informelles auraient peut-être suffi
s'il vous la pose officiellement c'est
parce qu'elle est me semble-t-il
révélatrices d'un malaise à tort ou à
raison la psychologie collective
française de condamner la classe
politique réduite à son impuissance
monsieur le ministre emmanuel macron a
lancé des pistes de réflexion de réforme
constitutionnelle et je veux rebondir
sur l'une d'entre elles celle de
l'amélioration de la qualité de la loi
il a été évoqué la nécessité de
simplifier la procédure législative est
d'accélérer le temps législatif le temps
démocratique et légitimement long mais
parfois trop longs à l'ère du numérique
certes nous sommes réticents lorsqu'il
s'agit de toucher à nos droits
parlementaires
mais à l'instar d'autres pays le sénat a
déjà expérimenté des procédures
d'adoption simplifiée temps c'est pour
notre lenteur permettez-nous à notre
tour de vous lancer sur la vôtre celle
de l'exécutif
monsieur le ministre le sénat a débattu
puis adopté le 13 juin 2018 une
proposition de loi sur l'utilisation des
caméras piétons
par les autorités de sécurité loi votée
définitivement le 30 juillet par
l'assemblée
la procédure a donc été rondement menés
des décrets d'application sont prévues
après avis technique et du conseil
d'état mais nous sommes le 14 février
déjà sept mois d'attentes et les caméras
sont sagement rangés dans les tiroirs
ses ministres par votre action ce
dispositif caméra piéton a démontré son
efficacité
à l'heure où les violences s'inscrivent
désormais dans le rituel du samedi
pourriez-vous réfléchir également à
accélérer le temps réglementaire
je ne mets pas en cause la qualité du
travail fourni par vos services mais je
veux dénoncer ce décalage incompris par
l'opinion publique
entre la décision politique et sa
concrétisation
pour vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur avait la parole monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur alors je vous évoquez un
décalage d'une incompréhension je vais
essayer de la levée le plus simplement
possible
vous avez raison de souligner
effectivement que ces caméras piétons
sont un outil précieux pour les
policiers pour les gendarmes et nous
souhaitons qu'elle le soit pour les
policiers municipaux
il ya effectivement une loi qui à
généraliser ce dispositif à l'ensemble
du territoire national après comme vous
le savez deux ans d'expérimentation
expérimentation qui a porté ses fruits
qui s'est avéré extrêmement positive
d'abord parce que ça permet de réduire
les tensions
lorsqu il y à des interventions des
policiers municipaux ensuite parce que
ça leur permet de réunir des preuves
judiciaire quand ils sont agressés et
enfin vous le savez très bien pour la
formation des policiers municipaux ces
caméras piétons sont très utiles donc
effectivement la loire à généraliser ce
dispositif et il y à un décret qui est
en cours de préparation
ce décret a reçu il a reçu l'avis
favorable il a reçu l'avis de la cnil
l'avis du conseil d'évaluation des
normes et le conseil d'état en est saisi
depuis janvier 2019 et ce texte est donc
à l'étude
je rappelle que ce dispositif est un
dispositif qui est extrêmement
contraignants comme vous le savez les
policiers quand ils rentrent au service
ne peuvent pas visionné au même les
images ils doivent les stocker dans des
conditions de sécurité optimum
et si ces dispositions réglementaires
sont adoptés si elle mérite d'être
étudié c'est d'abord pour
tgc fonctionnaires de police municipale
comme vous le savez comme nous
protégeons les fonctionnaires de la
police nationale et de la gendarmerie
nationale dans l'utilisation de ce
dispositif
je peux en tout cas vous assurer qu'il
n'y a aucune volonté du gouvernement de
ne pas mettre en oeuvre ces dispositions
bien au contraire puisque nous
travaillons dans le cadre de la police
de sécurité du quotidien dans le cadre
du continuum de sécurité que nous
souhaitons main dans la main avec les
polices municipales et il est bien
évident qu y compris dans le cadre de
patrouilles communes
il est tout à fait indispensable pour
nous aussi que les fonctionnaires de
police municipale soit dotée de ces
caméras piétons et tout va être mis en
oeuvre pour que ce décret soit publié
maintenant le plus rapidement possible
je vous remercie
merci monsieur lui dis-je la parole est
maintenant aux présidents philippe
dallier pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur ministre de la
ville et du logement les chiffres de la
construction pour 2018 sont connus ils
sont mauvais - 7 % viennent de paraître
les chiffres du nombre de logements
sociaux financés en 2018 ils ne sont pas
mauvais mais monsieur le ministre
ils sont très mauvais avec -20 % en
ile-de-france - 20 % en deux ans et -20%
en retrait par rapport à l'objectif de
2018 bien évidemment tout le monde
s'inquiète pour 2019 car il n'y a aucune
chance que la situation s'améliore alors
ça pénalise bien évidemment les français
qui attendent un logement social mais ça
va aussi pénalisé les communes
auxquelles au titre de l'article 55 de
la loi sru
on fixe des objectifs de construction de
logements sociaux
en 2015 le ces jeunes et des organismes
d'état avait déjà tiré la sonnette en
disant encore 2019
les deux tiers des communes risquait
d'être carences et parce que les
objectifs assignés était trop important
combiné à cette crise du logement social
que vous avez créé par vos choix
politiques
vous allez mettre beaucoup de communes
dans une très grande difficulté alors
monsieur le ministre quel instruction le
gouvernement entend t-il données aux
préfets de région qui préside le comité
régional de l'habitat pour que cette
difficulté soient prises en compte au
moment où sera jugée la bonne volonté
les maires pour construire du logement
social
merci pour vos réponses
la parole est tombée des charges et de
la ville et du logement
je m'unis je devais la parole monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président d'allier
vous évoquez les chiffres de la
construction dans le domaine du logement
social
on vient d avoir vous l'avais dit à
l'échelle du territoire national en 2018
on a engagé à peu près 100 9000
logements contre 113 mille l'année
précédente et leurs référentiels que
vous donner c'est un référentiel sur
l'année 2016 en ile-de-france qui était
une année exceptionnelle
je crois que vous le savez très bien et
que cette année là de manière de manière
générale en ile de france c'est moins 3%
par rapport à l'année dernière mais
c'est à peu près le même niveau que
l'année 2015
ça c'est la réalité des chiffres qu'on a
mais vraiment et je crois qu'on se
connaît suffisamment je ne suis
absolument pas là pour soi faire de
l'angélisme soit dire que les chiffres
sont bons aujourd'hui nous n'avons
absolument pas suffisamment de logements
sociaux
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire face à
ça il ya au moins deux choses qu'il nous
faut faire à très court terme
la première c'est de faire en sorte
qu'on lève les incertitudes les
inquiétudes qui aujourd'hui perdure au
sein du mouvement des logements sociaux
c'est notamment toute la démarche de la
clause de revoyure que nous avons
engagées à laquelle vous avez vous
participé
monsieur le président d'alliés pour
qu'on puisse trouver les solutions
notamment vis-à-vis des inquiétudes de
l'année 2020 que nous connaissons bien
la deuxième chose c'est de mettre en
oeuvre la réforme que nous avons porté
dans le cadre de la loi est long et j'en
veux pour preuve
juste un élément vous savez on a
beaucoup poussé et certains dansaient
ben poussé également pour un certain
nombre de regroupements au moment où je
vous parle il ya 3 140 structures de
logements sociaux qui sont concernés par
les regroupements
il y en a à peu près de 230 qui ont
entamé ces procédures de regroupement
dont quasiment les deux tiers qui sont
très avancées déjà dans un projet ou
bien avancé et ça il faut continuer à y
aller et à y aller avec détermination
enfin le dernier point que vous évoquez
c'est sur les carences sru vous
connaissez très bien le système et je
prends bonne note de ce que vous avez
donné
vous savez très bien que effectivement
il y à une appréciation des préfets qui
sont donnés dans le cadre des carences
et notamment dans le cadre de l'atteinte
des objectifs du triennal qui est fixé à
chaque fois j'ai pris bonne note de
votre recommandation monsieur le
sénateur monsieur le président
pis au moins sur le constat nous
devrions pouvoir tomber d'accord il y a
urgence pour le logement social
ici au sénat des républicains au parti
communiste tout le monde à l'automne
2017 et à l'automne 2010 8 vous a dit
que vos décisions allaient précipiter le
secteur dans une crise
nous y sommes nous y sommes alors il
serait fort de café monsieur le ministre
que les communes auxquelles vous avez a
signé la loi sinde objectif de
construction paient les pots cassés de
la politique que vous avez décidé de
conduire monsieur le ministre
regarder la réalité en face et prenez
les bonnes décisions merci
la parole est maintenant notre madame je
suis guidé pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président madame la ministre des
solidarités de la santé mes chers
collègues
l'épidémie de grippe touche de plein
fouet notre pays est à son niveau
maximum depuis le mois de janvier nous
dénombrons hélas près de 1100 décès à
cela s'ajoutent des services d'urgence
qui ne désemplissent pas les
complications respiratoires sans oublier
l'embouteillage classique des salles
d'attentes explique en partie ce
phénomène dans le département de
l'essonne à l'hôpital d'arpajon un
médecin réanimateur expliqué à france 3
que la priorité était donnée aux
urgences virale ainsi déclaré que willy
supplémentaires étaient ouverts cette
année surtout des interventions
programmées et des prises en charge de
chimiothérapie ont du être décalées
si donc un sujet de santé publique
sérieux qui n'est pas à prendre à la
légère et concerne l'ensemble des
français parmi la population les
personnes âgées de plus de 65 ans et les
enfants sont les plus touchés car ils
sont les plus fragiles
en outre selon l' agence nationale de
santé publique
les résultats préliminaires disponibles
en semaine 5 indique une efficacité fax
vaccinale chez l'ensemble des personnes
à risque de 59% contre le virus a h1n1
est de 19% contre le virus a h3n2 dans
le même temps et toujours selon le
bulletin d'information la couverture
vaccinale en france métropolitaine a
progressé de plus de 1 06 % par rapport
à l'année dernière pour l'ensemble des
sujets à risque par conséquent madame la
ministre
plusieurs questions se posent d'abord
pouvez-vous nous confirmer ce bilan
aussi même si est encore tôt pour tirer
des conclusions
qu'en est il vraiment de l'efficacité du
vaccin faudrait-il envisager comme
certains le proposent une obligation
vaccinale pour les publics fragiles et
les professionnels exposés
enfin ne conviendrait-il pas de
renforcer davantage des campagnes de
vaccination et de sensibilisation contre
la transmission du virus
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et à
madame à vis des solidarités de la santé
va la manière du jamais la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice justin guide s merci
d'intervenir sur un sujet de
préoccupation et de santé publique
effectivement le virus de la grippe
circulent chaque année chaque hiver en
métropole et les responsables de très
nombreux décès c'est un virus aux
conséquences potentiellement graves
surtout sur les chutes chez des sujets
fragiles les personnes âgées les
personnes qui ont déjà des pathologies
chroniques et cela peut évidemment
entraîner le décès cette année
comme chaque année nous sommes en pic
épidémique et les urgences sont saturés
nous sommes donc très attentifs à
renforcer les campagnes d'information
pour favoriser la couverture vaccinale
chez les personnes à risque dont je
rappelle quelles sont les personnes
âgées de plus de 65 ans les personnes
diabétiques les personnes obèses et les
femmes enceintes
nous avons également le souhait
d'augmenter la couverture vaccinale des
professionnels soignants qui est
insuffisante dans nos établissements de
santé nos établissements médico sociaux
pour cela j'ai fait deux mesures
particulières cette année j'ai élargi la
possibilité de vaccination dans les
pharmacies notamment les primo
vaccination ce qui n'était pas autorisé
auparavant dans quatre régions
françaises qui aboutit à 700000
vaccination en pharmacie et cette mesure
va être étendu à l'ensemble de la france
dès l'année prochaine cela a été voté
dans la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
par ailleurs j'ai demandé à tous les
ordres des professionnels de santé
qu'ils signent une charte d'engagement
pour favoriser la vaccination des
professionnels soignants
grâce à ces deux mesures qui démarre
nous avons augmenté la couverture
vaccinale de 1,6 pour cent
certes le vaccin cette année d'une
efficacité pas toujours optimale mais
même lorsque le plaquent ça n'est pas
n'a pas d' efficacité optimale il permet
de réduire les conséquences de la
maladie il permet également de réduire
la circulation du virus en semaine 6 en
médecine ambulatoire
ce vaccin aujourd'hui à une efficacité
de 74% sur l'une des souches et 21% sur
la deuxième en circulation mais nous
aurons des chiffres consolidés d'ici la
fin de l'épidémie dans quelques semaines
je vous remercie
merci madame vie des paroles et à notre
collègue a redoublé pour le groupe de la
république on marche pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président la messieurs
les ministres cher collègue monsieur le
ministre olivier du socle à qui
s'adresse cette question voilà déjà près
de 80 ans le statut des fonctionnaires
été créé dans le respect je crois de ses
valeurs et ses principes vous présentiez
hier soir une transformation de la
fonction publique aux partenaires
sociaux
nous savons cette transformation
nécessaire parce que le secteur public
au même titre que le secteur privé est
confrontée à des mutations majeures
la montée en puissance du digital
notamment de l'intelligence artificielle
et dans ce contexte les exigences
nouvelles des usagers pour un meilleur
service public nous la savons nécessaire
aussi parce que la fonction publique
fait face à un enjeu d'attractivité en
raison des attentes des jeunes
générations et du manque de mobilité
entre les trois fonctions publiques mais
aussi avec le secteur privé
nous la savons nécessaire aussi parce
que la fonction publique mérite
l'allongement des contraintes mérite
l'allègement des contraintes qui suscite
la précarité voir l'instabilité ou qui
limite le redéploiement des services
publics particulièrement en milieu rural
où son accès par l'apprentissage ou par
les professionnels par exemple
titulaires de diplômes d'état tels les
professionnels de santé depuis 40 ans il
est demandé aux agents publics de
s'adapter mais sans leur en donnait
toujours les moyens je pense notamment à
la formation des métiers sont interrogés
remis en cause les agents doivent
pouvoir bénéficier d'une seconde voire
d'une troisième carrière et ne pas être
laissés sur le bord de la route alors je
comprends que vous proposez plus
d'autonomie pour les cadres la
reconnaissance du mérite tant pour les
fonctionnaires que les contractuels
davantage de mobilité l'égalité de
traitement et de carrière entre les
hommes et les femmes notamment
il n'est pas
il n'est pas envisageable de maintenir
un statu quo quelques syndicats ont
pourtant exprimé des réserves
alors monsieur le ministre ma question
est très simple
pouvez vous nous indiquer la place que
vous comptez donner dans les semaines à
venir aux syndicats aux associations
représentatives des collectivités au
débat parlementaire et particulièrement
au sénat et bien évidemment aux agents
publics pour vous répondre la parole et
secrétaire d'état aux produits de
l'action des groupes publics
merci encore monsieur le sénateur arnaud
de béléné vous l'avez dit j'ai présenté
hier aux partenaires sociaux une réforme
du statut de la fonction publique
restant fidèle et à ses principes et à
ses valeurs mais avec la nécessité
impérieuse de le transformer d'apporter
des souplesses pour permettre à
l'administration d'être plus efficaces
mais aussi de donner droit nouveau temps
aux agents titulaires quant aux agents
contractuels
nous allons travailler comme nous avons
travaillé depuis un an avec les
organisations syndicales et les
employeurs publics pour avoir un
dialogue social à la fois plus simplifié
recentrer sur l'essentiel et protecteur
pour donner de nouveaux leviers
managériaux en termes de diversification
des recrutements d'amélioration des
conditions d'emploi des agents
contractuels pour mieux tenir compte de
l'engagement et du mérite et nous allons
aussi évidemment travailler sur la
question de la route de la formation et
des mobilités
c'est sur ce point là que vous avez
particulièrement insisté en soulignant
combien les employeurs publics doivent
être exemplaires à la matière ne le
sommes pas aujourd'hui pour permettre à
des agents dans le métier est remise en
cause par des évolutions technologiques
par des restructurations par des
réorganisations ou par les révisions de
politique publique de connaître une
deuxième ou une troisième carrière
ça nécessite d'améliorer le système de
formation initiale mais aussi le système
de formation continue des agents et
c'est l'occasion pour moi de saluer le
travail que vous avez menées avec le
député jacques savatier travail sur le
système de formation continue des agents
de la fonction publique territoriale et
vous avez remis un rapport à monsieur le
premier ministre mardi rapports utiles
précieux parce qu'ils explorent
différents scénarios il est né d'une
concertation et de rencontres nombreuses
sur le territoire et il va nous
permettre de nourrir les travaux en la
matière vous me dites qu'elle et vous me
demandez pardon quelle est la place
donne
dans le processus de concertation aux
organisations syndicales aux employeurs
aux parlementaires ainsi qu'à l'ensemble
des agents du service public
il s'agit d'une place forte nous avons
ouvert une concertation avec les
instances représentatives et j'attends
des organisations syndicales des
propositions de représentation
concernant les parlementaires votent
rapport est l'illustration des
améliorations d enrichir d
enrichissement que le débat
parlementaire nous permettra d'apporter
à ce texte pour construire une fonction
publique moderne rénové protectrice des
agents et au service des usagers
la parole est à notre collègue rémi
féraud dont le groupe socialiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
dans la guerre contre des shu ce sont
les kurdes qui ont neutralisé plus de
30000 jihadistes et chasser
l'organisation terroriste de tous les
territoires qu'elle occupait ils ont
pour cela sacrifier des milliers de
combattants ils se sont avérés des
alliés remarquable alors comment
accepter qu'à l'heure de la victoire
militaire
les kurdes soient abandonnées par la
coalition internationale
après le retrait annoncé de l'armée
américaine une fois privé de défense
aérienne et d'armes lourdes les kurdes
mais leurs alliés arabes et chrétiens
aussi vont se retrouver seul face à une
prévisible agression du président turc
et de ses supplétifs islamistes
nous ne pouvons pas l'accepter déjà
l'invasion il ya tout juste un an du
canton dafri nhs a entraîné des crimes
des destructions des déplacements de la
population kurde qui s'apparente à un
véritable nettoyage ethnique
alors face à une situation aujourd'hui
très inquiétante
il est indispensable que la france et
l'europe s'engage avec force
des voix s'élèvent et appelle à une
initiative européenne pour la création
par l'onu d'une zone de protection dans
le nord de la syrie cette zone de
protection dissuaderait toute invasion
de l'armée turque ainsi que le retour
des troupes du régime syrien
elle empêcherait l'expansion des
influences russe et iranienne et
favoriserait
une meilleure protection des minorités
dans les négociations sur l'avenir de la
syrie la france a là une occasion
historique de sauver l'honneur de la
coalition contre des ch
en se mobilisant réellement avec ses
alliés européens
j'ai une question pouvons nous compter
sur le président de la république et le
gouvernement pour agir en ce sens merci
pour répondre la parole et à madame la
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
mais madame darrieussecq problème la
ministre merci merci monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
monsieur messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur rémi féraud vous
l'avez dit nous sommes à la veille d'une
étape décisive au levant l'engagement
militaire de la communauté
internationale dans la région vise à
défaire des chais à permettre aux forces
irakiennes de contenir sa résurgence
l'opération shamal en formant les forces
irakiennes et en appuyant les kurdes
syriens et leurs partenaires permettent
d'achever la reconquête de lui
l'ultime bastion de dèche mais je le dis
aujourd'hui les terroristes s'accroche
aux quelques enclaves qui leur reste ou
se dit miss dissimulent au milieu des
populations civiles
nos alliés américains ont annoncé leur
retrait mais à la suite de discussions
ils ont conditionné ce retrait à la
défaite du califat territoriale et il
est également essentiel que ce
désengagement de syrie ne soit pas
précipités pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que nous aurons dans une
phase difficile de vérification de
terrain est la deuxième la situation
humanitaire s'aggrave et nous préoccupe
donc nous poursuivons nos discussions
avec les américains au sein de la
coalition pour donner des garanties aux
kurdes de syrie pour contrer les
ambitions iraniennes et pour éviter la
dispersion des combattants étrangers
et bien sûr nous continuerons à apporter
nos soutien aux efforts visant à la
stabilité de la région
ne nous pouvons abandonner les forces
arabes et kurdes qui ont combattu
vaillamment une solution négociée sera
nécessaire qui préservent leur secure la
sécurité leur sécurité mais aussi
répondre aux préoccupations de sécurité
les
tim de la turquie et dans ce contexte
très complexes vous en conviendrez
nous restons naturellement attachés à ce
qu'une solution politique puisse être
apportée globalement à la crise syrienne
et nous poursuivrons les échanges avec
nos partenaires que ferro pour quelques
secondes dit monsieur le président
j'entends la réponse de la ministre
j'entends l'intention mais je crois
qu'il faudra passer à un moment de
l'intention aux actes merci la parole et
à notre collègue cédric perrin pour le
groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre emmanuel macron a
décidé d'organiser le grand débat
concertation discussions/négociations
ouverture écoute sont les mots que le
chef de l'état martèle à juste titre
dans ses échanges avec les maires et les
français depuis quelques semaines il les
place au il en fait l'alpha et l'oméga
de sa nouvelle méthode de gouvernance et
il a sans doute raison
qu'importe que sa conversion au dialogue
soit tardive elle seule permettra de
sortir de la crise car on ne peut pas
réformer la société par voie d'autorité
cette nouvelle méthode aurait-elle
échapper à votre gouvernement une
réforme de la justice contre l'ensemble
des professionnels du droit
magistrats avocats greffiers sans écoute
des propositions du sénat qui vous a
tendu la main pourtant avec notamment
une table ronde un projet de loi santé
contre les professionnels du secteur
tous dénoncent un texte élaboré sans
concertation et dont l'essentiel des
propositions sera formalisée par
ordonnance 'l'annonce d'une réduction
des dessertes tgv
je ne crois pas avoir entendu les
français formulé une telle demande pas
même dans les grands débats une carte
pénitentiaire imposé aux élus locaux
sans dialogue ni concertation des
ordonnances pour réformer la politique
des déchets dois-je rappeler ici le
travail colossal des parlementaires sur
ce sujet comme sur d'autres sujets que
je viens d'évoquer
pourquoi mettre les parlementaires à
distance monsieur le premier ministre
vous pouvez le constater les exemples ne
manquent ne manquent pas ils sont
nombreux je suis pourtant convaincu que
la voie de l'apaisement est celle que
vous recherchez alors qu'attendez vous
pour mettre en oeuvre dans votre
politique la seule méthode qui vaille
celle de la concertation pour répondre
parole et au ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement monsieur
marc fesneau ne la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur père
j'aurais vous remercier dieu là votre
question et et du temps de votre
question parce que je pense qu'au moment
du grand débat on a besoin les uns les
autres à la fois de pouvoir débattre et
en même temps de pouvoir débattre
sereinement et c'est ce que vous avez
fait je voulais vous en remercier vous
alerter le gouvernement sur à la fois le
travail du grand débat non je n'en dise
on nous partageons évidemment ce
sentiment l'utilité de ce grand débat
est par ailleurs la traduction
législative est la manière dont nous
pourrions travailler avec le parlement
et vous noté un certain nombre de textes
sur lequel il peut y avoir des
désaccords
dois je vous rappeler aussi qu'il ya un
certain nombre de textes y compris avec
le sénat je pense à la loi ferroviaire
par exemple où nous avons trouvé des
accords et donc je pense qu'il faut
qu'on assume et c'est aussi la loi
démocratique le fait que nous puissions
sur un certain nombre de textes actes et
des désaccords et parfois même trouvé
des convois de convergence partiel et
puis sur d'autres textes qu'avec le
sénat qu'avec l'assemblée nationale au
travers des navettes ou à travers des
commissions mixtes nous puissions
trévoux de trouver des points d'accord
le grand débat est encore à l'oeuvre
le président de la république et le
premier ministre ont annoncé un certain
nombre d'étapes qui nécessairement
auront leur traduction législative à ce
moment là il y aura un débat au
parlement et nous comptons bien que le
parlement puisse se saisir de ces
questions parce que comme vous l'avez
dit le débat est nécessaire le débat
avec les français nécessaire mais la
démocratie représentative doit être
aussi renforcé dans son rôle d'interface
entre les citoyens et le gouvernement et
donc nous comptons bien travailler avec
le parlement le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale pour trouver des points de
convergence mais je dois vous l'avez il
se trouvera aussi des configurations où
l'on puisse ne pas trouver doit de
convergence et c'est aussi ça en
démocratie je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
seul mini je vous remercie pour
dialoguer il faut être deux et si le
décalage entre les annonces qui sont
fait qu'ils sont en train d'être fait
encore part le président en ce moment et
les actes se confirme le remède pourrait
être pire que le mal est sans doute que
la déception sera à la hauteur des
espoirs que les annonces ont provoqué
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue achats larcher pour le groupe
l'est républicain
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
elle porte sur l'avenir que vous avez le
pouvoir de réserver aux 240 salariés de
l'entreprise arjowiggins security dont
la liquidation judiciaire a été
brutalement annoncé mi janvier des
familles bouleversées des vies sans
lendemain ce sont 250 millions d'argent
public distribué par la bpi à des fonds
voyous qui se sont comportés comme des
charognards
arjowiggins et le coeur battant de tout
un territoire en seine-et-marne le nôtre
un savoir faire exceptionnel pour
fabriquer le papier sécurisé français
pour nos passeports cartes d'identité
cartes grises permis de conduire
aujourd'hui la seule en france à ce jour
nous en sommes réduits à mendier auprès
de la ministre du travail pour obtenir
un pays saut digne pour les salariés
je suis sénatrice de seine-et-marne et
je veux faire part à la haute assemblée
de mon indignation face à votre mutisme
j'ai écrit au président de la république
pour l'alerter sur l'extrême urgence à
intervenir
pas de réponse je vous en ai adressé une
copie ainsi qu'à bruno le maire pas de
réponse
hier christian jacob vous a posé une
question pas de réaction ou si peu que
faut-il faire pour attirer votre
attention
il serait inconcevable que la france ne
fabrique pas elle-même son papier
sécurisé pour ces documents officiels
c'est en france qu'il faut le faire et
pas ailleurs
qui d'autre car joe higgins pour le
faire c'est non seulement une question
d'ambition de stratégie mais aussi de
sécurité nationale
qu'attendez vous monsieur le ministre
pour mobiliser un financement pour aider
ses salariés
remarquable investi responsable a créé
une société coopérative
et participative qu'attendez vous pour
vous déplacer sur le terrain
ces salariés se désespère d'obtenir
votre aide concrète et nous aussi
pour vous répondre
la parole au secrétaire d'état auprès de
1002 l'action des corps public chez
l'homme merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice vous appeler
l'attention du gouvernement sur la
situation de la société un visioguide
security de juillet sur morin qui a été
placé comme l'ensemble des sociétés du
groupe arjowiggins en liquidation
judiciaire le 30 janvier dernier
vous l'avez rappelé cette ancienne
filiale du groupe papetier sequana la
société arjowiggins security qui emploie
265 salariés dont environ 220 sur le
site de production vous citez avait été
cité en oeuvre ces départs dont en avril
2018 par sequana au groupe ne mentionne
technologies détenues par le fond
germano-suisse parterre capital group
dans ce cadre le repreneur s'était
engagé devant le tribunal à limiter les
suppressions d'emplois et à soutenir
cette société dans ses efforts de
modernisation et de recherche de
nouveaux marchés
il s'était également engagé à subvenir
au financement des opérations par le
biais de divers instruments bancaires
notamment des garanties de 7 millions
d'euros qui devait être trouvé quelques
mois à peine après la reprise le groupe
bmt n'avait proposé aucun plan
industriel crédible et a toujours refusé
d'octroyer le moindre euro pour remédier
à une situation financière très dégradée
malgré les nombreux efforts faits par
l'état vous avez rappelé y compris
financièrement et l'attitude
constructive des salariés qu'il faut
saluer car ils se sont montrés
systématiquement ouvert pour améliorer
la compétitivité du site
la déclaration de liquidation judiciaire
confirme l'échec du groupe b mt et
l'irresponsabilité responsabilité des
dirigeants du fonds par terre vous avez
souligné madame la sénatrice combien
cette usine avait une production
importante notamment pour la production
de papier sécurisé monsieur le premier
ministre a eu l'occasion de répondre
hier au président jacob qui posait une
question sur le même sujet vous l'avez
aussi rappelé monsieur le premier
ministre a rappelé à la fois
l'engagement d'états l'engagement total
de l'état pour trouver des solutions
mais il a aussi dit et souligné devant
l'assemblée nationale comme je me
permets de le faire devant le sénat le
caractère extrêmement dégradée de la
situation vous connaissez ce site vous
connaissez la situation financière
nous pouvons ensemble pointé les
responsabilités de tel ou tel acteur
économique et privés qui ne tient pas
les engagements qui avaient été pris et
les risques que cela fait peser sur ce
secteur là il faut regarder cette
réalité en face
travailler ensemble hier la question
posée par le président jacob augurer
d'une vraie capacité des élus à se
rassembler avec le gouvernement pour
chercher ensemble toutes les solutions
possibles passé de faire du vent
aujourd'hui pour votre majorité la
question n'est pas de savoir si on doit
cocher la case parents ou parents de à
la place de père et mère mais de sauver
des emplois qui assureront une
indépendance à la france
[Applaudissements]
il en avons terminé merci monsieur le
premier ministre et dames et messieurs
les ministres c'est aussi suspendu elles
soient reprises à 16h20 nous
poursuivrons la discussion de la
proposition de loi relative aux délais
d'intervention du juge des libertés et
de la détention en rétention
administrative à mayer la science est
suspendu voilà pour cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
que vous avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur public sénat est à mes
côtés le ministre de la culture franck
riester bonjour bonjour d'abord votre
réaction à la nomination d'alain juppé
au conseil constitutionnel à ses adieux
émus à bordeaux lui qui était venu vous
soutenir d'ailleurs est bien pour la
fondation de votre parti à agir
oui bah écoutez c'était beaucoup
d'émotion ce matin à voir les images
d'alain juppé c'est une page de la vie
politique française qui se tourne
je suis ravi pour lui je trouve que
c'est une belle nomination pour le
conseil constitutionnel c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour le constituer le conseil
constitutionnel c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour le pays donc que quelqu'un d'aussi
expérimenté puisse veiller au respect de
la constitution au sein du conseil
constitutionnel bien évidemment en tant
que soutien d'alain juppé en tant que
quelqu'un qui partage ses valeurs ses
idées depuis tant d'années je suis
évidemment moi aussi un peu ému de voir
si un petit peu meurtri aussi par le
contexte des violences actuelles à
l'égard des peu des hommes politiques et
on a compris que c'était aussi au coeur
de l'une de ses motivations pour quitter
la libye non je pense pas que ce soit au
coeur de ses motivations je pense que
c'est une étape dans son parcours
une étape importante et encore une fois
il a marqué l'histoire de la politique
c'était un grand réformateur c'est
quelqu'un qui a toujours veillé à avoir
des propos modérés à mettre le débat
politique au bon niveau il va manquer à
la vie politique française mais je suis
ravi pour lui qu'ils puissent s'épanouir
maintenant conseil constitutionnel alors
franck y est très bien
l'actualité de votre ministère c'est la
réforme du droit d'auteur qui vient de
franchir un cap décisif au niveau
européen tout l'enjeu est bien
aujourd'hui c'est d'adapter ses droits à
l'ère numérique expliquez nous oui tout
à fait il ya eu un accord important ce
qu'on appelle en trilogue au niveau de
l'europe à bruxelles entre le parlement
européen la commission et le conseil
européen s'il ya des représentants des
chefs de gouvernement s'étaient pas
gagné on a beaucoup puisé beaucoup
d'énergie les parlementaires français
le l'équipe du gouvernement et puis la
commission pour trouver un accord un bon
accord la france était à la pointe de la
négociation pour faire en sorte que lier
la création au niveau européen de droits
pour droits voisins pour la presse pour
qu'il y ait une meilleure rémunération
des éditeurs de presse des agences de
presse et donc aussi des journalistes à
l'ère numérique sur les plates formes
notamment je pense à google news
ensuite il ya un article très important
pour faire en sorte de mieux rémunérer
les auteurs qui est un partage de la
valeur sur les plateformes de partage de
contenus audiovisuels et c'est une
avancée est très importante et puis
aussi que soit créé un droit clerc à une
rémunération juste et proportionnelle
pour les créateurs les auteurs les
artistes
voilà des avancées majeures dans ce qui
pour nous deux si important c'est à dire
de veiller à la préservation ce que ça
des auteurs des créateurs dans ce pays
très en euros à ce que ça ne va pas se
taper l'innovation sur internet c'est là
l'argument des grandes plates annoncé
tient pas du tout et il reste encore un
vote du parlement et un vote du conseil
européen sert les chefs de gouvernement
merci beaucoup franck reste avoir
répondu à mes questions et revient tout
de suite dans l'hémicycle alexandre
quels étaient les temps forts de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement entame cette séance a été
marquée par la condamnation par les
sénateurs tous groupes politiques
confondus des violences antisémites
notamment du week-end dernier et qui
sont de manière générale en forte hausse
en france en 2018 le sénateur rdse
olivier léonhardt a notamment dénoncé la
profanation ce week-end de l'arbre à la
mémoire d'ilan halimi assassiné en 2006
par le gang des barbares et au delà de
l'indignation les séries et les
sénateurs ont demandé des actes au
gouvernement pour lutter contre cet
antisémitisme edouard philippe a répondu
précisément et longuement il a d'abord
rappelé qu'une plateforme
pharos sur le web doit détecter depuis
cette année les propos haineux et
antisémites c'est une plateforme du
ministère de l'intérieur
et puis une loi en 2019 va engager la
responsabilité des réseaux sociaux qui
abrite tous ces propos haineux et
antisémites
et puis un travail de formation des
policiers et des magistrats est en cours
pour permettre de mieux détecter le
caractère antisémite de certains crimes
et délits aps
et enfin il faut nommer les responsables
de cet antisémitisme et le sénateur les
républicains dominique de legge n'a pas
hésité à le faire pour lui les
responsables sont l'extrême gauche
sioniste l'extrême droite et l'islamisme
radical
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
analyse et ce décryptage on va continuer
bien notre débris des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement avec vous
c'est vrai que perrin sénateurs l ère du
territoire de belfort merci à d'être sur
ce plateau on vous a entendu en
interpeller le gouvernement
justement sur une demande de mieux
associer le parlement à la décision
publique est ce que vous avez été
satisfait par la réponse ans et marc
fesneau qui vous a répondu écoutez je
n'ai pas eu de réponse donc à moi ce que
je voulais mettre en avant c'est ce que
nous ressentons tous ne peut pas y avoir
deux discours il peut pas y avoir un
discours du président la république
toute la journée sur les ondes qui fait
campagne pour les prochaines élections
européennes qui explique qu'il faut du
dialogue de la concertation de la
discussion qu'il faut entendre les corps
intermédiaires les élus etc
et puis que le gouvernement ici au sénat
comme à l'assemblée nationale face
complètement le contraire c'est-à-dire
travaille essentiellement par ordonnance
et la loi santé ne nous écoute pas celle
à la justice alors que l'ensemble des
professionnels ils sont opposés
travaille sur un certain nombre de
sujets via et via des ordonnances et
prennent des décisions qui sont décision
vertical sans nous concerter
voilà il ya deux poids deux mesures il
ya un discours et des actes
et il faut être extrêmement vigilant à
ce que
le les actes soit en conformité avec
avec les paroles parce que sinon le
remède sera sans doute pire que le mal
c'est ce que je disais et puis l'épreuve
les promesses qui ont été faites vont
être vite
comment oublier et je pense qu'il ya un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes qui
vont se retrouver fort déçu justement la
synthèse de ce grand débat c'est un
enjeu on voit que ça fonctionne plutôt
bien sur le terrain avec les citoyens
qui se prêtent au jeu qui en font
remonter leurs doléances qu'elle doit
être
les su comment on peut sortir par le
haut de cette consultation
l'important dans ce grand débat c'est
d'en sortir surtout je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on a bien compris que à
tout le monde a bien compris que c'était
il ya pas mal de danger à ce grand débat
aujourd'hui de prison de la république
se met en scène ya voilà il passe ses
journées à devant sur les plateaux de
télé phase ii en dehors des télévisions
etc à promettre beaucoup de choses la
quiétude que nous avons nous c'est que
comment vont être tenues l'ensemble de
ses promesses alors qu'il ya quelques
quelques petites comment tentatives
pour voir un petit peu de tout qui sont
lancés comme ça dans la presse pour un
petit peu quelle lettre va être ressenti
dans la population sur le fait que le
diesel on pourrait en discuter que la
taxe carbone ne pourrait être remise en
application rapidement etc et on sent
bien que moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
l'essentiel des demandes de gillet
joindre guillemets mais je pense de
l'ensemble de la population française
c'est aussi un besoin de pouvoir d'achat
or de pouvoir d'achat il n'est jamais
question danser dans ce débat là on vous
parle beaucoup d'institutions beaucoup
peut-être démocratie de problématiques
qui certes sont sans doute importante
mais qui ne régleront en aucune manière
la problématique des français vis-à-vis
n'a pouvoir d'achat qui est en berne et
et vis-à-vis de problématiques qu'ils
rencontrent eux au quotidien avec des
salaires qui ne leur permettent pas de
vivre décemment
donc tout ça et va nécessiter sans doute
qu'on s'en sort par le haut il y avait
des questions de ce fameux référendum
s'ils voulaient bien sûr perrin sur ces
questions institutionnelles mais on
retourne salle des conférences savez ces
principes de cette émission puisque le
thème fera nuit et avec votre collègue
sénateur est leur langue et pour une
autre réaction
oui gérard longuet votre réaction à la
nomination d'alain juppé au conseil
constitutionnel est ce que c'est pour
vous l'homme de la situation
en tous les cas c'est assurément son
choix personnel
on n'entre pas par hasard au conseil
constitutionnel c'est donc la volonté de
sa part de tourner une page et sans
doute d'achever une carrière publique
exceptionnelle par un mandat où il ya
plus de sérénité sur d'autres plus de
recul sur l'actualité immédiate
oui c'est ce qu'il a effectivement
justifier notamment sa décision par la
volonté travaillent dans un climat plus
serein et il a parlé de la
stigmatisation des élites dans le climat
actuel dans cette crise des gilet jaune
ou alors je connais alain juppé depuis
très longtemps depuis dès avant son
élection au parlement
et c'est un homme qui a enduré des chocs
brutaux coché toutes les cases de la
réussite française normale sup l'ena
l'inspection des finances des
responsabilités importantes très jeune
et puis la vie n'est pas linéaire en
tous les cas l'avis public lui a réservé
quand même quelques mauvaises surprises
depuis les grèves de 95 ou les
difficultés judiciaires qu'il
assumer pour le compte d'autrui je pense
que aujourd'hui le sim qui a pas grand
chose à attendre d'un climat politique
dit respect total l'égard des
institutions en général et des hommes
qui s'y dévouent en particulier bien sûr
aîné alain juppé va être très marqué par
la ville de bordeaux comment est-ce que
vous jugez son bilan aujourd'hui alors
que certains disent déjà et bien que sa
gestion
ça fait des caisses vides que ça va être
compliqué la suite alors les violences
de bordeaux mais ne sont pas familières
en revanche le travail fait dans la
ville est exceptionnel le patrimoine
naturel était superbe mais il a su en
tirer parti en modernisant la ville et
notamment en lançant ce réseau de
tramway qui est absolument indispensable
dans une agglomération en croissance
continue et où les problèmes de
transport sont il faut le reconnaître
extraordinairement complexe l'arrivée du
tgv à bordeaux au fond de cette ville
une métropole extraordinairement vivante
je pense franchement que les bordelais
peuvent le remercier
même si tout naturellement est à
reconstruire en permanence pour revenir
sur cette violence actuelle à l'égard
notamment des hommes politiques
est-ce que vous la comprenez un petit
peu ce que les hommes politiques ont
aussi leur part de responsabilité dans
ce oui ils ont leur part de
responsabilité je vais peut-être vous
surprendre parce qu'ils ont abdiqué leur
pouvoir je pense que le système
présidentiel français et en particulier
depuis le quinquennat fait que ni les
députés et par conséquent lundi les
sénateurs n'exerce le pouvoir
constitutionnel qui est le leur et
nous avons très souvent d'aider des
critiques justifiées elles et garde des
exécutifs successifs à gauche à droite
et et nous n'allons pas jusqu'au bout de
nos convictions parce que le soutien ou
le combat du président de la république
l'emportent sur tout autre considération
et je suis intimement convaincu que sur
des questions par exemple comme
l'énergie qui a déclenché les gilets
jaunes
on répète et homps elle me dit dédé des
formules qui sont en partie creuse et
injustifiée parce que nous n'exerçons
pas nos responsabilités politiques
merci beaucoup à gérard longuet pas
avoir répondu à mes questions
merci merci à vous pour cette réaction
cédric perrin on a vu aussi beaucoup
d'interpellation des sénateurs sur le
climat de violence qui règne en ce
moment en france à la fois des violences
antisémites avait que cette forte
progression le plus 74%
il faut et bien des efforts d'éducation
aussi une justice plus ferme c'est ce
qu'a dit le premier ministre à l'infini
oui je crois que le premier ministre a
été très justes les questions qui ont
été posées sur cette question était tout
à fait bien posée je crois qu'il faut
avoir
de ce point de vue là en tout cas une
union nationale totale on a besoin
évidemment
je pense de renforcer l'éducation la
matière je pense qu'on a besoin d'eux
expliqué un petit peu ce que c'est que
que ces propos qui sont tenus et ces
actes scandaleux qui sont perpétrés aux
quatre coins de la france savez moi j'ai
un grand père qui était déporté qui m'a
appris ce que c'était que ces valeurs-là
qu'il fallait les défendre et je pense
que moi je me souviens de mon grand-père
qui m'expliquait comment à la fin de sa
vie et qu'il avait toutes les peines du
monde à imaginer comment on allait
pouvoir transmettre une fois que les
derniers témoins ne serai plus là et
bien ce que les hommes étaient capables
de faire de pire et je crois qu'on a
besoin aujourd'hui de retravailler cette
mémoire et de retravailler sur ces
questions vous savez il ya quelques
personnes nostalgiques d'un régime qui
n'ont pas connu qui essaie de faire peur
qui non sans aucun doute pas conscience
de ceux de ce2 de ce qu'ils font pour
certains mais qui pour l'eau pour
d'autres ont parfaitement conscience de
la gravité des choses et de 2,7 de cette
haine qui ne sont en train de véhicules
et je crois qu'il ya évidemment cette
ses attaques contre contre des juifs il
ya eu un nombre incroyable d'église qui
ont été profanées et il ya les actes qui
ont été commis contre les arbres l'arbre
qui avaient été plantés pour ilan halimi
contre simone veil et c'est tout ça
n'est pas acceptable d pas tolérable et
mais il ya aussi les premiers me serais
dit serait juste quand il a dit ça il ya
aussi un problème avec les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui on peut tout dire
surtout n'importe quoi sur ces réseaux
sociaux et moi ce que j'avais dit au
moment des voeux d'ailleurs j'avais
formulé le voeu qu'en 2019 leno nos
concitoyens fasse preuve d'un peu plus
de réflexion et avant de transférer des
messages qu'ils savent soit mensongers
soit et ne bien réfléchisse à deux fois
je pense est important j'ai la
conviction que ces réseaux sociaux sont
même si on les utilise tous sont un peu
hein quand le cancer de cette société et
qu'on a besoin de les réglementer
davantage le premier ministre a été très
clair sur cette question je pense est
important quant au reste il faut être
extrêmement ferme lorsqu'on attrape des
auteurs de tels actes je crois que la
justice doit faire son travail et
beaucoup de sueur métier aussi des
violences contre les parlementaires
contre les élus est ce que c'est ce
climat d idées
qui en quelque sorte favoriser à libérer
justement de grande violence
je crois qu'elle est violent ce qu'on
creuse les élus il ya des violences
contre contre contre un peu tout ce qui
représente un peu le système il ya je
pense aujourd'hui une population
désinhibé qui est arrivé sur des
manifestations avec peut-être au départ
des intentions un peu moins violente
mais qui phénomène de masse et dans se
sont retrouvés un petit peu en capacité
d'exprimer leur l'erreur leurs
revendications par la violence donc il
ya une espèce de désinhibition je me
suis dit mission pardon de d'un certain
nombre de personnes qu'il faut
aujourd'hui remettre sur le droit chemin
il ya évidemment la blocks il y à des
extrémistes de gauche et de droite des
tentatives de récupération mais il ya
aussi des gens qui sont des gens je
pense tout à fait normaux entre
guillemets intellectuellement et qui se
sont laissés peut-être emporté il est
nécessaire que ça revienne redevienne
rapidement reviennent rapidement sur
roche
c'est ce que les mesures prises par le
gouvernement permettent de revenir c'est
un bon républicain c'est ce qu'ils
appelaient à votre collègue sénateur
olivier cadic tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle a je crois que c'est ce
qu'on appelle tous et toutes les mesures
qui tendront à faire en sorte que nous
puissions revenir à un ordre public un
le plus rapidement possible sont des
bonnes mesures
on voit les problématiques que
rencontrent les commerçants les
problématiques économiques que tout cela
génère dans une france qui maintenant
depuis trois quatre mois vit des heures
quand même plutôt difficile je pense
qu'on appelle tous de nos voeux à une
fin des hostilités entre guillemets on
voit aussi que l'opinion publique s'est
retourné et qu'aujourd'hui moi de ce que
je vois dans l'east la circonscription
où je suis je pense qu'on est au-delà
des 50 6 % de personnes qui
désapprouvent ses actions même si sur le
fond ils sont parfaitement conscientes
qu'il est nécessaire de faire quelque
chose pour le pouvoir d'achat j'insiste
là dessus est-ce que ça doit être une
sortie par un référendum
est-ce que ça doit être une question
institutionnelle une réponse
institutionnelle à ces questions
soulevées par le grand débat écoutez ça
je pense que ce n'est pas une question
institutionnelle aujourd'hui est la
problématique des français et les sur le
pouvoir d'achat certes il ya des des
d'autres sujets qui sont évoqués ici ou
là et ils représentent une partie
beaucoup moins importante que la
problématique du pouvoir d'achat il
faudra en sortir bien évidemment la
question du référendum a été quand même
assez bien traiter de ces jours-ci par
le président du conseil constitutionnel
qui a redonné les conditions et qui a
remis
en tout cas les choses en perspective
par rapport à l'organisation d'un
référendum il ya des règles et pour
pouvoir faire un fond mais il faut les
respecter
ba aujourd'hui on n'est pas en tout cas
en situation de le faire et je pense
qu'il est nécessaire le président
larcher avait fait une proposition qui
était très intéressante concernant la
démocratie participative est la reprise
de l'article 4 de la constitution qui
lui n'est pas utilisée sur le droit de
pétition
je pense que voilà une petite seconde
position avec un droit de suite et
évidemment la nécessité quand nos
concitoyens il y aurait enfin eu recours
à ce droit à ce droit de pétition et
bien un droit de suite la nécessité pour
nous en tout cas d'y répondre
c'est aussi la question finalement ça
viendrait peut-être
écoutez moi je suis frontalier de
l'astuce habite à 4km da suis donc les
votations comme on dit on connaît ça
même si la suisse a en tout cas les
suisses sont un état d'esprit
complètement différent parce que les
suisses sont capables de faire une
votation leur propose le smic à 2500
euros ils le refusent
on leur demande s'ils veulent travailler
moins il refuse donc il ya un autre état
d'esprit il ya une culture qui est
propre à cela mais je pense qu'on peut
faire confiance aux gens pour aborder un
certain nombre de sujets que nous
pourrons ensuite comment sur lesquels
nous pourrons débattre ensuite les uns
les autres avec je pense j'espère en
tout cas une réponse qui leur soit qui
leur soit donné merci beaucoup merci sur
le plateau de public sénat on va à
présent retrouver simon barbarie en saas
est une première pour un public sénat
sinon vous êtes journaliste pour le site
internet publicsenat.fr depuis le début
de la semaine et bien vont sillonner le
département des deux sèvres vous êtes
allés sur le terrain pour prendre le
pouls de cette grande concertation alors
ce soir vous êtes à airvault 7 au nord
du département des deux sèvres
vous allez assister dans quelques heures
un débat est ce que les français que
vous avez rencontrés se sont emparés de
ce débat alors je pense qu'on pourrait
des composés des populations qui
participent à ces débats en trois
catégories
évidemment les élus locaux les
conseillers municipaux et conseillers
département alors eux ils participent de
bonne grâce aux débats il respecte les
thèmes proposés par le gouvernement
comme les finances publiques la
transition écologique
après il ya deuxième catégorie qui est
bien représenté c'est les retraités eux
ils parlent vraiment de leur pouvoir
d'achat de leurs problèmes comme par
exemple les transports parce que si
c'est un département très rural il n'y a
pas beaucoup de trains pas beaucoup de
lignes de chemin de fer donc songer de
prendre la voiture
donc autant dire que la taxe carbone ça
leur plaît pas vraiment non plus et puis
il ya une troisième catégorie ils sont
moins nombreux mais ils parlent beaucoup
ce sont les gilet jaune il faut savoir
qu'ici à des problématiques locales par
exemple j'étais hier à niort lors d'un
grand débat organisé par le département
où il y avait 400 personnes et là bas
ils ont des revendications très
écologique qu'il ya une polémique par
rapport à des bassines d'eau qui ont été
autorisés par le département des
bassines d'eau qui sont censés c'est
pour les agriculteurs qui pratiquent
l'exportation et là bas ça ne plaît pas
du tout est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
sinon les thèmes qui ressortent de ce
grand débat
alors il ya les institutions il faut
dire que les élus n'ont pas bonne presse
et considère qu'ils ont trop de
privilèges qu'ils ont trop de retraite
qui ne travaillent pas assez
une personne disait que le président de
l'assemblée nationale s'arrangeait pour
faire voter les réformes impopulaires la
nuit en catimini il vient évidemment
comme je le disais le pouvoir d'achat ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'important
et puis surtout il rappelle que s'ils
participent à ce grand débat c'est grâce
au gilet jaune et il regrette que les
thèmes proposés par le gouvernement ne
concerne pas les gilet jaune il y avait
une personne hier à niort qui disait là
vous me parlez des échelons
administratifs vous dit
faut-il supprimer les échelons
administratifs y faisait mais moi ça
m'intéresse pas du tout moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de parler de la
souffrance des gens donc ce que je peux
dire c'est que c'est vraiment un
sentiment d'oubli qui est ici une
fracture territoriale
merci beaucoup à simon et votre travail
est à voir sur notre site internet et la
page facebook au site de public sénat
à 18h ce soir c'est aussi une première
sur public sénat l'émission un dialogue
citoyen présenté par rebecca fitoussi et
bonsoir rebecca de hausse hors d'âge
difficile et oui on vous viens
d'entendre simon voit qu'on en a
peut-être besoin de dialogue citoyen je
voudrais juste d'abord précisé public
sénat
ça fait longtemps que la chaîne donne la
parole aux citoyens je pense à des
émissions comme tous président ma voix
compte toutes les semaines dans nos
reportages dans nos portraits on donne
la parole aux français c'est juste que
là on a décidé de changer un petit peu
le format de leur donner la parole
pendant une heure et demie une émission
d'une heure et demie en direct on va
donner la parole à neuf citoyens qui ne
sont ni des leaders de syndicats ni des
présidents d'associations ils vont nous
faire part de leur situation de leurs
difficultés au quotidien de voilà de
tout ce qui se passe autour d'eux et ils
pourront poser toutes les questions
qu'ils veulent à six sénateurs et
sénatrices qui ont bien accepté cette
invitation qui seront présents sur ce
plateau
les élus de leur côté pourront leur
apporter des réponses peut-être des
solutions peut-être qu'ils seront aussi
amenés à j'ai envie de rendre des
comptes à justifier telle ou telle
mesure telle ou telle loi
on va évidemment pas balayé tous les
sujets qui font débat en ce moment on a
choisi quelques-uns bien précis la
fracture territoriale dont on vient de
parler
simon barbarie la crise de la démocratie
dont il vient de parler aussi
et puis on doute que la question du
pouvoir d'achat va probablement
s'inviter sur la table des discussions
l'idée c'est vraiment de les laisser
échangé dans un climat serein mais aussi
constructif
on veut surtout pas créer de tensions de
clash qui serait stérile on voit ces
violences verbales et physiques on veut
simplement créer ou recréer du lien
entre les élus et les citoyens on en a
bien besoin
eh bien merci beaucoup rebecca dialogue
sétoise citoyens c'est donc en direct à
18h sur public sénat c'est la fin de sa
manne 360
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi est bonne
si des programmes sur public sénat tout
à l'heure 18 heures
[Musique]